lovely i'm sending you live now you'll
be ready in about 10 seconds
thank you
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
the
council meeting of the 22nd of february
stratfor district
council this is the council's virtual
meeting
and everyone is asked to add here to the
etiquette
of virtual meetings as published on the
council's website
a few notices regarding housekeeping a
few reminders
please ensure your device is fully
charged or is charging
these mute microphones when you are not
speaking
please indicate in the chat bar if you
wish to speak
and please only use the chat bar to
indicate that you do
wish to speak and for no other reasons
when invited to address the council
please ensure your microphone
is switched on and switch off
immediately after you have finished
please ensure you have switched off or
to silence
any other devices you have that may
interrupt our proceedings
and remember in the event of any member
encountering i.t
problems causing them to drop out of the
virtual meeting
they should use their best endeavors to
rejoin as quickly as possible
should the member be unable to rejoin
the meeting they will be deemed to have
left the meeting at that point
and the meeting will continue numbers to
call should you experience any i.t
problems our it help desk on oh one
seven
eight nine two six double zero two zero
or caroline our democratic services
manager
on oh seven nine seven six four one
six three five three
please note that these proceedings this
meeting is being broadcast live and that
members of the public
are able to view the proceedings
i will just briefly uh mention and
remind you of the
change on the voting procedure in
respect of
virtual meetings when a motion has been
moved and is seconded if nobody wants to
speak there will be an
assumption that the motion is agreed
without the need for a formal vote
unless somebody indicates in the chat to
the contrary and therefore i will pause
after each item to allow such uh comment
in the chat box
and if nothing is there we will assume
the growth
the motion has been agreed
a new item that you haven't heard
previously
if members are intending to propose any
amendments
could they please indicate and write
them in the chat
as soon as possible this does not refer
to any written
amendments already received and
circulated
prior to this meeting that is the only
exception to the use of the chat
other than when you are wishing to speak
before turning to the agenda i would now
like to propose
a minute silence in memory of those
of our district who have sadly died
during the pandemic today thank you
so
thank you
[Applause]
bill members please note that there have
been some changes to the sequence
of the agenda item 15
working together with warwick district
will be brought forward to item
seven the political balance which
will not now be heard is no longer
relevant item
17 the investment in the materials
recycling facility will also be brought
forward
to item 12 so that it will precede the
treasury management statement
and the annual investment statement
2122.
the following amendments to the
recommendations of the cabinet
of the 9th of february have been
published members will have received
notification and copies of
those amendments and now call upon the
head of the paid service david buckland
to report any apologies received and to
take a roll call of the members in
attendance for this meeting
councillors by confirming you are
present you are also confirming
that you can hear and see the
proceedings
mr bartland counselor tony dixon here i
can see
and here thank you thank you chairman
apologies has been received from
councillor
andy crump i will call customers names
and if they could
upon me calling their name repeat their
name and confirm that they can hear and
see the meeting
thank you councillor champ because it's
enjoyed completely so councillor fitter
councillor theater i can confirm i can
see and hear the meeting
thank you councillor adam
counselor adam here i can confirm i can
see and hear the meeting
[ __ ] council [ __ ] here i
confirm i can see and hear the
proceedings okay
councillor barker i confirm i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor bromage yeah i can
confirm i can see in here proceedings
thank you councillor cargill council
cargill i can
see and hear the proceedings
counselor please i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you curtis councillor curtis here
i can see and hear proceedings thank you
thank you councillor adam i can confirm
i can see and hear proceedings
if you cancel the field in cancer
fielding i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you fleming cancer flaming i can
confirm i can stand here all proceedings
thank you
cancer yes i can hear and say thank you
cancer foreman
cancer performance yes i can see and
hear the proceedings
thank you professor ian pretzel and
counselor ian factory i can
confirm i can see and hear the
proceedings thank you
for jenny frenchley council journey for
actually
confirm i can hear and see the
proceedings thank you thank you
councillor harris
councillor harris i can confirm i can
see and hear the proceedings
thank you councillor harvey council
harvey i can see
and hear proceedings thank you thank you
mr hendrickson i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you jefferson counselor jefferson
i can see and hear the proceedings thank
you catholic jennings
councillor jennings i can hear and see
the proceedings thank you councillor
junette
councillor juned i can hear him see the
proceedings thank you councillor kendall
councillor kendall i confirm i can hear
him see proceedings
thank you kettle
counselor kettle i can confirm i can see
and hear the proceedings
thank you mills council meals i can
confirm i can hear and see proceedings
thank you
o'donnell councillor donald confirm i
can hear
and see the proceedings thank you tesla
parry
councillor parry here good afternoon
everyone i can hear
and see all the proceedings thank you
thank you councillor pemberton
thank you i can see and hear all the
proceedings
thank you
here i can see and hear the proceedings
thank you tesla richards councillor
richards i can see and hear all
proceedings
thank you councillor riley councillor
riley i can see
and hear the proceedings
counselor rock i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you uh cousin wolfe councillor
rolfe i can see
and hear the proceedings thank you
councillor shenton
councillor shenzhen i could see and hear
the proceedings
it was going so well thank you
councillor wally hoggins councillor
wally hoggins i can
see and hear all proceedings thank you
chairman
thank you david uh moving on to item
two of the agenda disclosures of
interest
uh i believe council of rolfe has a
declaration to make
and i invite others to indicate in the
chat
thank you chair in relation to item 25
councillor questions i've asked a
question about the over 65
permits my husband has a permit so i
need to declare that
but the monitoring officer has advised
me
that it is in order for me to put the
question and if necessary a
supplementary question
as this issue is likely to affect a
number of other people in my ward
and i believe that a reasonable member
of the public knowing this
would not would not believe that it
would affect my view of the wider public
interest thank you
thank you council rolf i
nobody else is indicating in the chat
any declaration so i now
invite officers to make any declarations
uh in respective declarations of
interest please to the meeting
nothing in the chat thank you very much
indeed let's take care of item
two moving now on to item three the
minutes
to confirm and sign the minutes of the
meeting held on the 14th of december
as i've already announced within my
welcome uh
there is to avoid the necessity of a
roll call in respect of the minute
it has been agreed to indicate in the
chat if you have any objections or
abstentions
if none are received i it will be
assumed that you are in agreement with
the accuracy of the minutes
i'll just give that a moment for you to
indicate in the chat
thank you members nothing indicating
right i will sign the minutes at the
part of this uh this meeting moving
through now
to uh item four announcements
we started this meeting remembering
those residents of the district
who have sadly lost their lives due to
covert 19.
i would now like us to show our
appreciation of all the many volunteers
who have stepped forward to help
in the rollout of the vaccination and in
this regard councillor cleave has
contributed in her role as a member of
the st john's ambulance service
i don't see sky news i have to say i
understand there was an interview there
which was a very excellent
and good interview i did see councillor
cleve however i think it was on midlands
today at the start of the rollout
what i would now like to do is to give
all members
an opportunity to please unmute and
we haven't done this before but on a
thursday evening we used to clap
in respect of the nhs and those hard
workers
looking after us all i'd now like to
clap for a minute
in support and thankfulness of all the
volunteers who've been helping
please
[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Applause]
she
[Applause]
perhaps my clapping was a bit quicker
than a minute i'm sorry about that
i only went up to 60. but so what i
would now like to do is i'd like to
invite councillor cleveland to say
anything
that she would like to add uh any
comments etc in that regard
councillor cleve thank you chairman yeah
i just
thank you for that thank you everyone on
i think that i can safely say thank you
on behalf of all the volunteers
i can say i know there's a lot within
stratfor district who have stepped
forward
through st john and other organizations
and
them and the nhs have done an incred
incredible job with this vaccination
so thank you for that and thank you
behalf of everyone
and i just wish to thank them as well
they've made they're making
us get back to normal quicker i hope
well thank you thank you councillor cave
knowing that i was coming into the
capsule chambers today i went and had
a uh a quick test and came through
negative
so i'm thankful for that and of course
i'm i'm somewhere between 14 and 21 days
into my immunity as such i having had
the job and it
all went extremely smoothly up in that
studly village hall for me
there is one other uh slight amendment i
will announcement i would make
unfortunately at home doing my diy i put
my back out
so once an hour during today's session
there will be a slight
two-minute break as i walk around the
council chamber
because it's not good for me to be
sitting still for two or three hours
etc and i would advise other members
equally well to take the opportunity to
stand up
and uh i'm sure cam burroughs would
probably uh suggest some exercises for
you at the same time
but uh essentially after we've been
going for glass an hour
we'll have a two minute break uh we will
of course have a comfort break later on
uh i would now like to invite the the
leader and the chief executive
to make any announcements first the
leader
thank you chair uh i think
there's been no nothing other than
routine business since our last council
meeting
i would however just like to say that as
you can probably tell from my voice
i'm suffering from a very very sore
throat
uh i will try and be mercilessly brief
in everything i say during the meeting
but i have to say
my voice may not last out until the end
of it
thank you counselor jefferson uh
david any announcements uh two thank you
chairman firstly
my thanks to staff again for their
ongoing after uh the kobe pandemic and
another thing might be proud of all
their efforts the second is response to
a comment made by mr uh counselor which
is in the chat he looks plays a punch
with a tap
yes i was so worried that we were going
to break the internet at that point and
it it worked fantastically so
that would be my second announcement
chairman thank you
we now move on to item five uh
a sad movement uh where we reflect
from former councillor les topham
les was elected in 1996 to represent
sanborn ward
one year before i was myself elected
we both served in the cabinet with les
as a deputy leader
taking over the leadership in 2005
when councillor saint resigned from that
role
les was a larger than life character
very proud of his achievements
having worked at british leyland in the
days of red robbo
in time he branched out and started his
own fencing business
and garden center not only rightly proud
of his own business achievements
he was a proud to represent stratford on
avon
as the chairman in 2001 to 2002
and also proud of his county and of his
country
having a warwickshire bear and a union
flag
in prominent positions at his home next
to his garden center
indeed les will be sadly missed i now
ask if councillor jefferson and then
councillor juned would like to comment
and then i'll open it to all members
obviously
thank you thank you chair uh
i will be brief i did not join the
council until well after
uh less topham had left uh
i have no real direct knowledge of him
but uh from his reputation he was
obviously
a very good person and a very effective
counselor
thank you tony uh councillor junaid
councillor rock uh will speak on my
behalf
thank you councillor juliet castle rock
uh thank you chairman um i did know
les topham and um i liked him very much
actually
uh obviously he he and i were on
different sides and as you say was a
larger
life character uh i had quite a few
dealings with him because
at that time the audit commission uh
carried out an assessment under the cpa
system that there was there
and we didn't do very well in that we
had a weak assessment and
during that period less brought about
quite a change in the way uh
of the culture of the council i think
and um because i was
the shadow for the corporate affairs
portfolio at that time i had quite a lot
to do with him
in bringing that about and um
i thought he was quite a gentleman and
in fact
he and i several times attended the uh
country warwickshire sully hall forum
together so
i remember well although he was very
larger than life and possibly run
busterous
when he resigned as chairman of the
council he was actually quite emotional
so he got a soft center as well so
i liked him very much thank you chairman
thank you councillor rock
uh councillor pemberton
uh thank thank you chair um i think uh
along the side nigel i'm one of the few
members who
uh were around at the time that uh
les was a counsellor and leader and
chair
and as has been said already was a
larger than life character no one could
fail to know
when les was in the room um and in a
good way um
he was rambustuous um but he did it with
a smile on his face
uh he was always direct and he was
always helpful
um and as nigel alluded to at a time
when this authority was in
not a good place certainly uh
not the place that it's in now um les
took it all on the chin rolled his
sleeves up
engaged with everybody and he um
as part of the process brought hazel
wright into the cabinet
he reached across because he saw it was
the best thing to do for this council
it was the best thing to do for his
residents and whilst he was always
very firm he always had that at his
heart
and uh like nigel i also recall when he
was stepping down from chair
where no one could fail to appreciate
how much uh serving the residents of
this district meant to him
and um i shall remember him fondly as uh
as uh as as one of one of life's good
guys thank you
thank you councillor uh councillor
kettle please
uh thank you mr chairman yes during my
period of as as chair of this authority
it was always i could always guarantee
uh
that um les would continue his interest
in the council he was always at the back
uh for our council meetings um
keeping an eye on making sure that um
the track
he had set it on was continuing uh he
took a keen interest in in the
council and i think um that showed his
devotion to what
he felt that we he he was a chi
achieving
and what he hoped we'd achieve as well
thank you thank you counselor castle
no other councillors have indicated a
wish to to speak
so i will now move the the formal uh
motion
that the council notes with regret the
death of former councillor les topham
district councillor for sanborn award
from 1996
2000 leader of the council from 2005 to
2010
and chairman of the council from 2001 to
2002
and extends its sympathy to his family
and friends in their loss
i so move
moving now through to item six public
participation
i believe we have a question
has mr weaver telephoned in
i understand we're having a few
technical issues contacting
mr weaver we'll be trying to contact mr
saint
but we'll just give that a moment or two
while we try to achieve that connection
thank you
um
okay councillor st can you um the
committee
i can see council dixon looking into
space is he expecting me to respond
counselor saint can you hear me
counselor saint can you hear me
i should bring my microphone slightly
closer can you hear me counsel the saint
faker pardon mr saint i can hear you
very vaguely
would you like to uh
would you like to put your question
yeah well the questions have been put in
writing as required
i've got an answer um i'd like to follow
it up
thanks for jefferson for the answer
but on the first question he talks about
authority for the reports based on joint
statements of leaders
and the anticipated one paper which i
don't think has ever come
yet but however i would have expected
some form of
one council acting on behalf of the
others and a proper notice of decision
have been being given
was that done
councillor jefferson
are you there councillor jefferson with
the answer to that
question from mr saint
sorry i'd forgotten to remove
i i followed the process as was advised
by
officers
thank you councillor jefferson mr said
he followed the procedures as advised by
the officers
so a second question i'll accept that
thank you do you have a supplementary in
respect of your second question
the second question yes um
is a better answer
[Music]
but effectively i accept what councilor
jefferson has said
but i'm thinking ahead there's quite a
big difference between the council
tax levels of flatfoot and warwick
district
when any merger has taken place
uh do we expect this council tax level
for stratfor district to rise
to something closer to what warwick
district now
levy uh
if i may respond mr saint i think the
level of council tax for
any new council will be a matter for
that council
not for us
thank you councillor jefferson i'm sure
you must have given some thought to it
i have given it
uh there is a considerable amount of
thought being given to a councillor
saint
i think the issue actually is that
uh given that the county council
warwickshire county council of have
already submitted a business case
for the department for a
single warwickshire unitary i think it
is inevitable
that there will be an increase in
council tax should either a single
unitary
be created or should a joint south
warwickshire council
be created uh from the figures we have
at the moment
it looks as though uh the council tax
for
stratford-uneven residents would be
higher
in a single unitary solution than it
would be
in his south warwickshire solution
okay thank you and thank you mr saint
uh have we managed to make contact with
mr weaver at all
i am now advised that mr weaver who put
the first question
uh is not uh coming to uh the council
for a supplementary
so that takes care of item six the
public participation
uh moving now through with uh
the item agenda seven is no longer
required
uh in respect of the political balance
calculation
and we've moved uh gender item 15
working together with warwick district
council to this point in the
uh agenda i therefore now invite
councillor jefferson as leader of the
council to introduce
this item council jefferson uh thank you
chair
uh if we look uh working together with
warwick district council
uh this is almost certainly the biggest
strategic decision
we as councillors will have to make
it's about the principle of further
integration
including a potential full merger with
water district council be incorporated
incorporated into the policy framework
of the council
i think we all need to be clear what
this decision is not about
it's not about comparing the option of a
potential full merger
with warwick district council with
remaining independent
of stratford district council in reality
as i was saying in response to mr
saint's
question that ship said last year when
warwickshire county council made a
submission
to the department of housing communities
and local government
for the creation of a single
warwickshire unit unitary council
so we have to decide whether potentially
creating a south warwickshire council
is the best strategic and i emphasize
the word strategic
option for us cabinet have explored the
options in depth
and are convinced that the proposal is
the best option
by far we recognize there'll be many
challenges
uh ahead in the creation of the south
warwickshire
district but we are confident we can
manage them effectively
there will be many issues of detail to
be worked through
today however the issues are those of
principle
and strategy not of detail
there also needs to be a recognition
that many decisions will be
for the new council to make the world
has changed
and our role as councillors is to create
a strategy that does
our best for residents in responding to
the changing world
i would at this point like to thank
councillor susan junit and nigel rock
for positive discussions on this issue
and i have committed to much
closer dialogue in future indeed
once the principles have been agreed by
both councils
then working through the detail we need
the involvement of
all councillors a greater level of
dialogue and involvement will be
essential to ensuring that there will be
full support and commitment going
forward
so we end up with a really effective
solution
for our residents staff and councillors
i do not believe this is a party
political issue
this is about the best strategic
decision
for the council and the best future for
our residents
i urge everyone to support the
recommendations
as a beginning of a new and exciting
journey
and a new and exciting future for south
warwickshire
thank you chair
thank you councillor jefferson i'll call
upon a second uh in respect of those
proposals
and then we'll open the discussion as i
see that there are
four councillors and starting with the
junior but i'll
need the proposal being seconded first
please
please
thank thank you chair uh yes i i second
this
and reserve my right to speak at a later
point if needs be
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor junior you were first to
indicate
yes thank you at this stage we are being
asked to
agree a vision statement and an
in-principle roadmap
but we do need to be clear that all
further stages will be reported back to
all councillors for agreement
we want our dem group to be kept fully
informed
and able to do our job of scrutinizing
properly and i do
thank both councillor jefferson and
councillor pemberton
for the the chance to talk through some
of these issues
a great deal of work will be required
before a final decision is made and the
public
must also be properly consulted i would
like it to be miniatured
that while supporting recommendations
one to nine
the council also notes the benefits
likely to arise
from a north and south unitary system of
governance
and expresses the hope that the merger
of stratford and warwick district
councils
will be a first stage in moving towards
that unitary system
but i would also like it to be minuted
that the council recognizes the
value in ensuring that all councillors
are kept fully informed and included in
the work required to meet this vision
thank you and i do hope that this passes
today thank you
thank you chair in response to the
letter my group received which
specifically mentioned me
and my reasonable questions regarding
the proposals that we are considering
today
and the fact that i did not immediately
respond i say this
never ever mistake her silence for
weakness or acquiescence
remember that sometimes the air stills
before the onset
of a hurricane the consultation period
that all councils had
regarded the proposals before us today
is woefully inadequate
we are being asked today to make a
decision that will affect each and every
one of our residents
for many years to come and perhaps even
their lifetime
we received our papers a little over two
weeks ago
and we have had an hour-long briefing
regarding it we certainly haven't had
time to disseminate or discuss it with
our parish councils or residents
in our awards to be treated with such
disdain
is totally unacceptable and i refuse to
treat those that elected me
in the same way as those that are
leading us today seek to do
our residents across the stratfor
district need us to help them rebuild
after the substantial effects of covid
they need
our council to have the capacity to help
them when they need it
we need to continue to be on the most
effective service
we need to spend the next 18 months
repairing rebuilding and reassuring
the proposals before us today
significantly reduce those capabilities
as
officers will be more focused on the
joining together of warwick
levington spa district council with
stratford we stand to lose
highly respected and experienced
officers who love the stratfor district
and have spent their whole working
careers dedicated to the residence
there has been an unprecedented interest
in retirement courses
not necessarily driven by age but by
antipathy
of working outside an area that they are
devoted to
losing experience and dedicated officers
is
not an option while we rebuild postcovid
how do i know this because officers
speak to me
and i ask the right questions and have a
reputation
that makes me approachable we absolutely
need
calm before we face local government
reform which i acknowledge
is coming but it isn't coming yet we
need to wait
we need to see what financial settlement
stratford will receive because it is
coming
in his letter to tony jefferson dated
the 7th of december
luke hall minister for regional growth
and local government states
the kovig 19 pandemic has rightly
necessitated resources
across whitehall and in local government
being reallocated
to tackling kovid 19 and on economic
recovery
and this must be whitehalls and town
hall's
number one priority he is indicating
that there will be enough money to focus
on recovery
rather than wasting it now on local
government reforms
as a member of the finance task and
finish group i can assure members
that there is enough money to tread
water for a little while longer
while we look at all proposals for the
future of sdc
in a more measured and sustained way
with much better consultation of members
and far more engagement and consultation
with the electorate
stratfor district and its residents need
to have a loud and
proud voice for their future i was
elected to represent my ward as a member
of stratford district council
not as a super south councillor and not
as a warwickshire unitary counsellor if
this leadership does not feel that the
needs of our residents is being
conveyed strongly enough in recovery
groups then i suggest that you appoint
better more articulate voices with the
gravitas needed to do this
i want to have officers working for the
residents of stratford-upon-avon
who actually know how to get to
mappleberry green or that little compton
is some distance from long compton
i do not want the services to be run by
officers who know nothing about our
district
we are not similar we are very different
we are not
levington spa or warwick we are
stratford upon
avon and we are on the world stage
i refuse to support this in its current
format
and at the present time this will be the
curtain call
on all that we hold so dear to our
hearts
our residents and our district and our
heritage
is worth so much more than this so
i urge each and every one of you to vote
against the proposals
that you have before you this is being
done to us
and not with us stratfor district
council
can and must be better than this
thank you chair thank you council
wally hoggins uh councillor
o'donnell was was next in the in the
list please
thank you chair so i fully support the
government's
pre-covered drive to streamline local
government
and make it nimble and more cost
effective providing value for money for
our residents
as you'll be aware we held an extra
meeting of overview and scrutiny last
week to scrutinize this proposal
i've noticed the fact that we had to
request this extra meeting
highlighting the lack of pre-decision
scrutiny thus far allocated to it
but moving forward i'm pleased that to
advise that both the council leader
and the chief executive have agreed to
attend osc
every two months to update re-progress
around this
however a number of questions remain
unanswered for us
as a committee where is the public
consultation and stakeholder
consultation evidence
and where are the supportive statements
from our local mps
even given the whitehall letter shared i
see no explicit support for this
specific proposal
i would suggest that at the very least a
round table with warwickshire county
council and every district council in
the area
chamber of commerce and local mps should
have been at the start of this
to provide a consultative and engaged
vision for how we could all work
together
rather than combative approach which has
left us with our main stakeholder out of
the equation
now rather than a supportive stakeholder
we have a powerful
local opponent on our doorstep
potentially this could weaken our case
when the proposal is viewed at whitehall
and i'm still unclear around how the
public consultation will take place
or the percentage of residents needed
for this proposal to be accepted
no referendum is planned due to cost
which is understandable
but we will need clarity around public
consultation
i also and we as a committee asked why
now
ask every member here and their families
what their main focus is at present
and i suggest it's not local government
reviews the topping of
the topic occupying everybody at present
is covid
and to echo council wally hogg's
statement both the secretary of state
for housing communities and local
government the right honourable robert
generic and luke hall minister for
regional growth and local government
both used identical wording in their
responses to us
that the covid 19 pandemic has
rightly necessitated resources across
whitehall and in local government being
reallocated to tackling kerbic 19
and on economic recovery and this must
be white halls
and town halls number one priority at
present
timing is key our residents need us to
focus on emerging from covid as strongly
as we can
and to introduce this proposal now risks
local poor local engagement and poor
quality public consultation due to lack
of
lack of engagement and potentially low
turnout our other question as a
committee was
what is plan b because it wasn't clear
from the proposal
well it's not clear because there isn't
one and this is highly concerning
and also at the heart of all of this is
our residence i wasn't elected
on this and have no mandate for this
from my residence oh and this point has
been raised regarding the proposal not
being on our manifesto
we've been advised that neither was
covid but you know what cove it wasn't
our decision and wasn't of our making
but this proposal most certainly is an
active decision and is a bar making
i'm really concerned regarding the
increase in resident numbers to members
ratio
a constant phrase i hear from our
hard-working cabinet and lead members
is a lack of bandwidth to the incredible
increase in workload due to covid which
is
understandable and is admirable how
they've coped with his increased
workloads
but how on earth will it work with fewer
members and more residents especially
when there was one worrying solution
expressed in the deloitte's report of
and i quote
exploiting the opportunities that modern
technology offers to increase engagement
between residents and elected members
many of my residents have no reliable
internet and i'm incredibly concerned
about
our older rural members and how they fit
into this proposal
and they are the people i represent and
finally what is not clear is whether the
budget forecast
is with the worst case scenario approach
we do not yet know what the government
spending review will be
whilst there is a possibility of the new
house homes bonus being removed
it is surely highly unlikely that given
the build back
better promise government would not
replace new homes bonus
in some way to keep encouraging
development
also once we emerge from kobe there is
an argument that our income will
increase as people return to our
wonderful
district and spending and planning
applications and car parks etc increases
i understand that joint working features
in our budget and there is no reason why
this proposal
which has many merits cannot be looked
at post-covered
and our continued joint working continue
and expand
i fully appreciate that change must
happen and only the nimble and flexible
survive in these uncertain times
however our proposal must be robust for
whitehall
based on the new census not one that's
11 years old
the proposal must be timely and fully
supported by our residents through
transparent public engagement
therefore as chair of overview and
scrutiny i still have many questions
left unanswered
at this stage to the level i would
require them to be answered
thank you thank you council
donald you timed that uh meticulously to
the five minutes
uh i've now got uh councillor bromwich
and then that we uh councillor uh
harris and councillor parry to follow
councillor brunch council brothers nick
please
yes first of all that we are as has been
stated by just about everybody we
know local government reform is coming
one way or another
first question is is now the right time
that is something
we need to be debating that but the next
part to me
concerns me with this proposal is
that through experience consultations
can be skewed to give you a right
answer i was citing sound a couple of
years ago
we had a local consultation about
whether the town council
should construct a set would develop a
new cemetery or not
such was the way the consultation was
put it was overwhelmingly rejected
because we and those in the know knew
that's what the town council wanted
some of you may have noticed that later
on i have asked the question
about a referendum we cannot
go forward with this without carrying
the public
not one counsellor here has been elected
on a mandate
to merge in and create this new super
authority
and if any you think at the moment
seriously you can do it without a
referendum
then you should put your money where
your valves are you should hand in your
resignation notes and stand on that
mandate
and see what the public wants that is
how great
serious this is i've done an initial
consultation
around southampton via social media and
talking to people on the street
what became obvious was actually a lot
of people were not convinced about a
southwestern district council
in fact there was a sizeable number that
wanted this area to actually move
to rugby borough council or could go
down a watcher unit tree
this is why it's important that first of
all you do your proper consultations
you put all the information out there
not like we got at the moment why i
don't think we have all the information
apart from oh we're gonna save some
money that
we're gonna join up some services and
that's what it appears to be but what
residents say is
what benefit is this to us in joining
other
council cost cutting we've got to sell
any changes to local government to those
residents at the moment this proposal
does not sell
it people are not convinced about it
when you actually get to the ground
level they're unhappy about it because
that lack of discussion the lack of
openness
many people were surprised to know this
was even on the table
because it's not been good information
put out there
whether it's been about watching youtube
or south boxier
district people want to know the full
truth if we are going to proceed with
exploring the potential options
it's not just one option that's on the
table we know there's
two options at the moment possibly that
and we have to put the information why
one option is better than the other now
i know
that certain councillors who are also
part of the county council
have argued southwestern council is more
beneficial
because otherwise it's too remote if you
come to south many you councils have
argued that
they would say the same about their
relationship with stratfor
so bear that in mind there when you're
talking about that sort of thing what
you need to be doing
is getting the information there before
making a decision
the full information has to be put put
before us as councillors
we don't have to decide which direction
we want to proceed
at the moment i don't feel we have the
full facts we have some skewed reports
through various proposals on the table
but the full facts are not there at the
moment
tell us why this is going to be a
wonderful benefit to the residents
that is leadership job and then it's a
job versus counselors to sell us
sell the public that at the moment we
can't sell that to our residents
and we do not have a mandate to actually
form this authority
we need that mandate as well
thank you councillor bronwich uh
councillor harris
thank you chair can you hear me
yes yes yes for harris to continue
thank you um as you're aware i'm a front
line nurse
dealing with covered patients and i have
to say we're certainly not out the woods
yet
so going forward we need to keep that in
mind because
we may have more lockdowns and the
impact on our residents
and society will continue it's a corona
virus it's not going away
this will be an annual event i have to
be honest i'm undecided about this
that we're deciding today i have
listened to members and colleagues in
the offices and agree like them
we need to be cautious we need time to
settle
after this past year and the way things
are going forward
i have a main concern with some of the
um things that have been raised by
um councillor wally hagan and uh
panian o'donnell um i have to agree my
concerns around the rural areas
i have worked in communities for years
as you all know my background
and year on year regardless service
level agreements and
any policies etc etc and being in a
rural area i see it day to day
we are constantly neglected and we're
left out
regardless of what puts in place
everything does
get drawn into the towns and the cities
and i fear that the services to our
rural communities and
um the way we uh do local government
will get worse
we should as councillor bromwich has
said involve our residents
and our parish councils they're key
especially when you look what's coming
down
the pathway that they're expecting
parish councils to take more
responsibility
and be more involved in local
decision-making i don't think we've
involved them
enough i'm also not convinced yet
whether we go through county
or the current um process
now that they will give us a savings
claimed
and if i can't see these benefits or be
reassured i don't know how i'm going to
convince my residents
or even my parish councils so at the
moment i think
people should be cautious and i'm not
convinced it's the way forward
not at this moment thank you chair
thank you councillor harris uh
councillor parry next please
thank you chairman we were all elected
by our residents to make decisions
in their best interests and so being a
councillor is about making
the big decisions an often very
difficult ones
at the right time for the right reasons
this afternoon we all have a big
decision to make
in fact it's the biggest decision ever
to face
councillors here at stratford district
and that is either in favor
or against exploring i use the word
emphasis
exploring the unique opportunity
for a merger with warwick district
council to form
a south warwickshire district council
resulting in savings
of 4.6 million pounds
over the next five years but members
need to take note
that voting against this proposal means
that our budget
fails and is a vote against the
council's medium-term
financial strategy for 2021
22 to 2025
26 can i also
remind members this is a decision about
exploring the opportunity
to further joint working and will
involve public consultation
and anyone who has been involved in a
major business merger
knows it takes time and
attention to detail which will take a
long time to develop
and therefore we are not talking about a
done deal
but it's the start of a new journey
should any member be thinking of
abstaining then this reflects
your inability to make a decision on
behalf of your residents
who didn't vote for you to sit on the
fence
and be indecisive the facts are quite
simple there is no viable alternative
so this is the time to unite together
and do what's right for our residents
and in their best interests in my view
there is only one choice and that is to
vote in favor of the proposal
as the two districts combined have the
potential
to create a super district which will
deliver
huge benefits and cost saving
and improved services to our district
thank you chairman
thank you councillor parry casper adam
next please
thank you chairman um i i appreciate a
lot of what's been said already but i am
very much in support of this
um this proposal i think ultimately we
are being
um forced to to make an ultimatum by by
the government
and that has been taken out of our hands
as a local authority
um and it's also something that means
that the time scale is
taken out of our hands when i was
elected this was not
um a key issue that i would have been
able to campaign on and yet it has
developed and is a real issue that we
must
address now um i welcome what the leader
said
when saying that this is not political i
don't believe it is um i think it is
the case that we have to make a decision
based on what is right for our for our
residents
um now looking at this i feel very
strongly that a
warwickshire unit tree is not
necessarily in the best interest for our
residents when looking at the cost
savings but also looking at
the geography and practicality of
providing services
that's why i do support a south borax
unitary um
combining warwick and stratford
districts although
um i i'm very happy being a stratfor
district councillor
i i see the real reality that that is
not
something that is being made sustainable
for the for the future
um in and of itself and if that means we
have to adapt then
then so be it um and as a result
i mean i think um what what was um
stressed by counselor junaid is that we
do need better consultation we do need
to work together on this so that all
counsellors are totally informed and
that we can scrutinize the plans that
this council
uh goes forward with uh particularly in
in being able to
consult and work in our best interests
for our residents
however i feel very strongly that this
is something that
we need to send a signal about now to
indicate that
this is the direction of travel we want
to go in we can then consult better we
can then make
informed decisions better in how we
realize that vision
and that's the point at which we will be
able to
scrutinize work together and consult
uh in the way that's needed um so as
a result i will be voting in favor of
this and i would urge my colleagues to
do the same
because i do believe it is in the best
interests of our residents
thank you councillor adam the next
councillor
indicated is councillor
thank you
i have a real problem with consultation
uh the district stratfor district not
very good at consultation
but that's another that's another story
um
i would i would like to see a delay
of a few months maybe six months
to allow for proper consultation with
our residents a delay on this
decision i don't believe it will have
any effect on the budget set
we're asking for a delay of six months
maybe july
to make this decision this will give us
time
to give the council time to consult with
the residents to iron out further
details
before we make this decision i would
like to see a delay
thank you thank you council ralph
the next council is councillor harvey
thank you chairman
there are numerous points which have
been made which i i could take issue
with
um perhaps i could start with uh
councillor bromwich
when councillor bromwich was um elected
he undertook uh the prime role of a
councillor
to represent his electorate to provide
leadership community leadership and to
be prepared to take
the strategic decisions facing the
council
now he has to speak as he finds if he's
spoken to his residents
and he finds that there are a majority
of a particular opinion which is not in
favor of this
then he has to reflect that i have to
tell him
that in discussing with my residents
particularly my parish councils
i haven't found anybody who's opposed to
it they all think this is a good idea
because they can see the inevitable and
so they're not prepared to sit on the
fence they are prepared
to see this go through
the question that we really face is
what are the alternatives we had a
question from the public mr
saint raised the question about what's
the likelihood
of council tax in a new regime
in a new council and we all know the
answer
that this particular council has for
many years pursued with vigor the
prospect of having the lowest council
tax
in the uh in the county and so it has
and there are other councils which would
be taken over
if uh the county council had its way
because we would then find that far from
being
149 pounds per band d property as is
proposed
in this council there are councils in
the
in the north part of this warwick county
which have
uh council tax rates of well over 200
pounds
the prospect therefore is that either we
uh lay the foundations and i do echo
uh susan junits cancer junaid's uh
uh after thoughts so to be quick and put
it not unkindly
uh that this she hopes that this is the
precursor to a south warwickshire
council i i echo that and i support that
and we need to take into account that
the timetable is being set
um not by us it is being set by by the
government and
is being added to by the county council
it is a matter of fact that the
county council railroaded through their
cabinet a proposal
to put forward a unitary solution for
the whole of warwickshire
they did not consult the district
councils at all
in fact they didn't consult members of
their group
they had to have a meeting after the
event where they strong-armed tactic
people who were opposed essentially
opposed
in order to to get that through uh the
county council
when the white paper is published
towards the end of the year i presume
um the race will be on and the county
council has
already got its bit of paper in in the
in the council office
in the in the department's office
whether we like it or not if we are not
in a position to respond
then by default we will find ourselves
in in a unitary council and the one of
the consequences of a unitary council
will be a democratic
deficit we as we sit around this table
so to speak
represent on average something of the
order of 2800 residents
if we move to a south warwickshire
council i suspect
that we will have larger wards and we
will represent something of the order of
my figure three and a half thousand
if we have a single unitary council
we will have a divisional
war and you will have county wards where
we will have
numbers i suspect in excess of 10 000
residents per councillor
that doesn't that's no different from
from that's a little different from
where we are at the moment
the crucial difference of course is that
there will be no
district council layer in between
so the alternatives you're facing are
either
a unitary council which is
going to happen unless we do something
otherwise
or a a unified county
sorry a a unified district council
between stratfor and warwick
where we maintain as best we can the
democratic connection
with our residents which we will lose in
the alternative
and we will gain the advantages that
councillor parry has has remembered we
has referred to uh financial savings
and i i must take issue with councillor
bronwich's point about i think his words
were something like
a can slanted report wind up you've had
your time
uh uh thank you chairman uh
i'll some i'll surmise by saying i think
we need to get off a few
a few seconds just to wind up we need to
get off the fence we need to do
something positive
we need to give some leadership and we
need to strike while the while while we
can
thank you chairman thank you councillor
harvey
uh the next councillor is councillor ian
fragili
thank you chair um i do have some
reservations particularly where i
understand there is a public
consultation stage
a consultation stage rather than a
public referendum
but i personally am sure the public
particularly stratfordians
will be most interested in how it is
going to benefit them
how much their council tax will be and
what the alternatives are to a south
warwickshire council
and i think i need some assurance that
all these
things will be dealt with during this
phase
thank you
thank you counselor frankly
is uh next in my list
thank you chair um yeah i think um
council harvey has actually made most of
the points that i wanted to make
and the government direction of travel
is is going towards um
larger local authorities and we're left
in a bit of a rock and a hard place i
feel
um so i think the the the point of a
democratic deficit and that's my
that's my biggest concern is that um
we're going to have a whichever council
we go for
it's going to have less councils and big
awards and that that's a big worry of
mine
um and then obviously there's all the
benefits of the cost savings that have
been mentioned before by other
councillors
so um on balance
doing nothing puts us in a bit of a void
and that's where a unitary authority for
the whole of warwickshire would set in
would set in so i think timing is very
important
and i think to move move quickly but
with
proper consultation with the general
public
and good communication to take them on
board
is really important so on balance i'll
be voting
um for this
thank you council if i check the next
one
is council all cockpit
thank you chair um
i can see so many benefits of this
moving forward
i can see all the benefits as they as
they come up and as counselors are
mentioning them
problem is i can't see the benefit of
doing it now
we my ward is instructed upon having
town
stratfor navy town is one of the worst
hit
areas in the whole country
caused by coven 19. tourism is decimated
there are businesses who have received
no support from the government
at all and so are struggling
our focus my residents want
my focus to be on how do we get out of
this
how do we bring our businesses back
how do we bring tourism back when there
can be no tourism
how do we come out of everything that
we've been
put into due to this virus
lockdown works we've seen that but now
we have to work on getting
out and getting businesses and people
back
that is what i think our focus
should be on we're looking at making a
huge change but
where is the benefit for our residents
now
all i can see is by going ahead with
this
straight away gung-ho straight into it
let's go is it the residents of
our town that are going to be affected
by that and it's a residence in my ward
i can see the benefits of it i'm not
disagreeing with anything that you've
said though
i do think council having your numbers
are slightly off
um 100 000 residents in a single unitary
would only mean 25 councillors but i i
get the general gist of what you're
saying
why now a six month delay on this
would give us time as a council with our
offices to help build
back our area that has been so decimated
that is where the focus ought to be and
this won't change in six months time six
months we can come back to this
very very easily we just have to look at
is now
the correct time i don't believe it
is and i'd much much prefer a six month
delay on it
thank you chair thank you council royal
[ __ ] uh
councillor curtis nix please
thank you chair yes i find myself in
agreement
not surprisingly with much of what
council old cook has just
said about the six month delay um
just picking up council harvey's
response to the council of bromwich
where council harm says that
we're elected to represent our
electorate among other things
but my question really is how can we
properly
represent our electorate if we're not
given adequate time
for proper open and transparent
consultation
with our residents um i think there is
already
unfortunately a degree of mistrust
between residents and the council
and i think moving forward without
proper consultation and gaining resident
support
can only increase alienation at a time
that we really really need
to be taking residents with us i
am fully in favor of the south
warwickshire
unitary but again i think that
we need to take our residents with us
it will be difficult as has been said
already
to persuade people of the benefits and i
think we need
time to be able to do that and explore
it without
feeling that we're being bounced into
this without
sufficient time thank you
thank you councillor curtis the next
councillor
is councillor jenny fragili
uh sorry just had to uh and mute et
cetera thank you very much chair
i've always been in total and full
support
of merging services some years ago which
never happened
i'm also in total and full support of a
south
um unitary rather than a whole unitary
because that is where the
hopefully we will actually be able to
keep um
a democratic relationship a closer
democratic relationship with with our
residents
i think a lot of the problems we've got
today are completely and utterly
down to in inadequate consultation
a lot of the conversations that we're
having now which have put people's minds
racing because of all the possibilities
we're talking about
we should have had cross party
discussions
set up by sdc and warwickshire district
council
where all councillors could have
actually had these conversations and
heard
all the issues which are now being
raised
we've only had as a party probably about
i said 48 hours to actually get our
heads around this
i mean this is really inadequate i want
to vote for this because i do
think this is the first step
it's not the final step and it might
fail but this is the first step
to get this out into the public domain
and to give
us and residents a chance to discuss it
but before we even discussed it
as a cross-party issue and it was
introduced as a cross-party issue
without that consultation it makes it
extremely difficult
we've got to work together on this
as different parties independence
liberal labor whatever whatever
we've got to work together otherwise it
won't work for our residents going
forward
i'm extremely disappointed that i'm put
into
a conflicted position at the moment
i'm still listening to the debate and i
still haven't quite decided exactly what
i'm going to be doing
and that is completely down to
inadequate
and proper consultation before we got to
this point
thank you thank you chair
thank you councillor frankly uh
councillor kettle is the next on my list
thank you mr shonen um
i completely understand councillor alcox
um raising the issue of covet
uh and we've heard from councillor
harris uh who is after all
and has been i think for 12 months now
on the
on the front line of kovid which i have
to congratulate her for that huge
huge effort she's been making along with
her colleagues
um but covid is not the only
item on the agenda covered we have to
learn to live with it
kavid will be with us as she says for
many years to come
and that is a horrifying thought
but that doesn't mean we have to abandon
everything else
we have to consider and we have to
continue
we have to look to the future we have to
look to
as to how local government will look
in two three five ten years time
and as council harvey has clearly set
out
one option is very clear because the
county council without any
consultation with any of us as residents
or even with um that
that their lower level authorities the
district councils
they've already put a paper in front of
the government
what we need to understand is we are
putting forward
a pro work a working proposal
to move towards a ultimately
a merge between two local authorities
but it is not we will not today be
making decision to say
yes it is going to happen or no it is
not
there will be huge opportunity for
public consultation
but we need to determine what we are
going to be consulting on
therefore we need the two authorities to
work
together which is why we're also looking
forward
to putting a budget as is warwick
district council
a budget to work out what the plan
will be and what that plan will then be
consulted on if we go through every
single minute eye of decision
and expect the public to comment
knowingly
on the a's the b's the c's the d's the
e's and the f's
and many more then we will have to we
will have to present that same
information to them
we need to give our chief executives and
the management teams
the opportunity to work out what it is
going to look like
and then there will be a decision
to go out to consultation and there will
be a decision by both
warwick district council and stratfor
district council
as to whether that proposal that is put
on the table
is going to happen ultimately the
decision will be made by the minister
but we cannot move towards a decision
without proper investigation without
proper
due diligence without proper research
for that proper this
and other and what we are saying today
is in order to move towards that merger
we need to carry out the due diligence
and that is what we are doing when we
have done the due diligence we can make
that case
to all our residents and if they don't
like it and they come back and say 99
of them don't want it i'm sure the
minister will take that into account
but it is something that we have to move
forward
and we have to find a way to do so and
that requires
the two authorities to work out what
this is going to look like
is it something we may look at it in
whenever whatever period of time turn
around and say no that is something
which isn't going to work
but we have to give the two uh
management teams the opportunity to work
together
and then put that proposal in front of
our residents and in front of the
minister
at some point in due course in terms of
um
local representation i understand
completely
uh councillor promises ongoing concerns
about being at east of the district
i don't think um council bromage
you need be concerned this will
i would think enhance southern's
position
if we were to merge because you'll be
more in the center
so anyway i'm going to shut up at that
point mr chairman
all i would say is this is an
opportunity we should not miss out on it
and if we miss the boat because we
present a half [ __ ] solution
to the minister because we haven't spent
enough time on it
and he demands an answer and he's got a
uh a confirmed position from
warwickshire county council
and he's got something which is not
complete by other authorities including
ourselves
i know which way he's going to decide we
need to get on with this
and put something on the table thank you
very much
thank you councillor kettle councillor
cargill you're next on the list
thank you thank you chair um i suppose
listening to this debate which is i
think has been very very interesting and
thank you all for your comment
is that of course i've been um i've used
word living and breathing this for
for some time now and i appreciate that
others haven't been as involved as
perhaps the cabinet have
who have been working very hard on this
behind the scenes so as to speak
um but just to go from the other
comments
uh when this whole thing kicked off
my best part of the year ago i suppose i
did engage with my residents i did
discuss it with them not in the detail
because we don't have the detail yet
but in the grand scheme the overarching
vision of it
and like council harvey everyone that
i've talked to and i'm not being
i'm not saying that just for the sake of
it no one has complained and said they
don't agree with it
it is a logical process most people get
it
but i discussed it thoroughly with them
so again i don't have a problem
and interestingly it was my residents
who came to me and said
will this lead to a south wales unitary
because we don't want a
full warwickshire unity it was them who
put this forward yes we thought about it
of course we had but it is they who
suggested it
casper alcock and uh
you comment about time and i do
appreciate it it's people don't want to
be
feel they're being rushed into decision
making
i don't believe we are today but i'll
come to that i wish we had more time
we don't we have very very little time
we have
got to put forward a budget for the
medium-term financial plan and this
this is part and parcel of that plan
and this merger part of it will be a
fundamental part 4.6 million pounds over
the planned period
we can't afford not to have it if we
delay
now we are in danger of not having a
a viable plan in our section 151 officer
may not sign off that budget so what do
we do then
and these are the problems that we we
have it is it is a problem for us
all and also to go back saying
um i think council o'donnell said well
i'm sure the hmg will give us some more
money later on because you know the
bouncer well
they have borrowed 400 billion
pounds i do feel that they're going to
be a little short of cash
maybe some down the back of the sofa i
don't know
but i'm not holding my breath and we
cannot as a prudent
financially responsible council and
cabinet
even consider that if we don't know it's
going to happen
we wanted a three-year settlement we've
only got one year settlement
that says something to all of us so
we've got to consider that element a bit
too
one other thing i do want to pick up is
about the residents
in that initial proposal when we did
that those uh
those presentations if you all remember
the powerpoints
uh what we did say that i'm not going to
paraphrase the mppf is
we have the golden thread running
through it it's all about the residents
and that i'm passionate about because i
do live in a rural
area and i i know how difficult it is
for people to engage
so i am passionate i am absolutely
certain
that my residents are very very well
represented and i do believe that this
is
one way we can do that i've got some
great ideas on this
and i want to make sure that we can
actually do that but we need to be in
control
if we are not in control over this all
right
we will be have we be done to as opposed
to having us
do it and that would be for example
when if it was to go to a single unity
as an example
we would be done to buy the by the wcc
and i have my serious concerns about
that
the north and the south of the workshop
county council are completely different
um on the consultation side yes we've
got to but this
this whole um strategy
leads to that it's part and parcel of it
we we will have
to engage with residents the secretary
of state will turn around and say well
you haven't done your job properly of
course we're going to do that
but i i can understand the concerns
about not engaging properly but
it's fundamental we have got to do that
as part and parcel of the process but
this is the stepping stone
on to that if we can get this through
today
and i do hope all members will vote for
it then
the next stage will be our consultation
process it will be
trying to tot a few eyes and cross a few
teeth we're
long way away from that yet but let's
let's get this first stage over
members i'm i'm okay i would say this
because i'm on the cabin and i've been
promoting this for some time now but
i really do hope your your vote for this
today
because i think it is absolutely
essential for our council
to progress into the future and be in
control of our own
destiny thank you chair
thank you councillor cargill uh the next
councillor i
have on my list is councillor rock thank
you chairman
um i i'm going to try not to repeat many
of the things that have been said
but i think the first thing to say is a
lot of members are having difficulties
with this because
they see they've been taken by surprise
from it and
as as the leader said at the beginning
uh
councillor julian myself have had some
meetings with himself and uh
councillor pemberton and i i'm i'm sure
councillor pemberton
and councillor jefferson will remember
that's more or less the first thing i
said to him
you should have spoken to a sooner about
this
and i think that has flavored some of
the comments that have been made here
however we have to bear in mind what
we're voting for is the words on this or
voting
on is the words on the the order paper
here and what what we're looking at
is is perfectly reasonable and i think
people are talking about
something else something that might
happen further down the line when we get
to make a yes no decision
on the basis of what we find out and
consulting uh with our residents and
consulting
uh with ourselves is dependent upon we
find out so we can't decide about
something unless we know
more and more information about it um
there you're quite everyone's quite
right there is a question about
timing uh and i think councillor wally
hoggins started off with a uh
a sort of weather analogy i i would say
um
as william shakespeare did there is a
tide in the affairs of men
which taken up the flood leads onto
fortune and the tide i think is running
in in in the direction of larger
authorities
and indeed that that's happening
it is already happening both in
warwickshire and up and down the country
so we've got to respond to that and we
don't want to get
caught caught out behind that tide
that's running
so we do i do think we've got to do
something now and this is preparatory
work
so i i would um suggest that
uh everything that's been said as
they're all valid points
and it's a difficult decision to think
about but we're not making the full
decision now
we're looking at investigation and uh i
i regret to say i agree with everything
counter kettle said which is
is going to surprise him terribly but i
think he put it very well
we're not actually making the decision
right now
to to jump straight in we're going to
find out about all these things and it
could we
could be we decide it's an inappropriate
thing for us to do for our residents and
for the interest of the district
it could be refined find out it is so
i i would commend everybody to vote for
the resolution that's written on this
piece of paper
and uh i hope that is what happens thank
you chairman
thank you councillor rock still a few
more councillors to uh go who indicated
counselor cleave thank you chair
um there have been many points that have
been mentioned in this debate that i
agree with so i'm not going to repeat
them all
in the interest of time i have to admit
that both councilor wally hoggins and
council o'donnell give a very passionate
and convincing arguments
and i do actually agree with much of
what they said however as
councillor junit and councillor rock and
others have stated this is all
currently in principle and we're voting
to explore the merger so i believe
nothing is set in stone
it sounds like change is inevitable due
to central government plans so now
unfortunately we are stuck making a
decision
on which is the lesser of two evils for
our residents all future options will
cost our residents more money
so my decision will be back based on
what will have the least impact on the
household budgets
if the future is unitary we essentially
have no say in the matter
in the changes that are coming to us
therefore if we are to move forward
i'd rather make the move that will lead
us towards the south unitary
which will be less of an increase in
council tax to our residents than a full
unitary
my question though is why have we not
gone straight to exploring a south
unitary
would that not be an option and why is
the cabinet not spoken to us sooner
this should not be a political game at
this point this should be about us all
working for the benefit of our residents
and residents only
thank you
thank you cats for the cleve uh
councillor barker please
thank you councillor dixon um i'd like
to associate myself
with uh what counselor rock has said
which will surprise him as much as
his surprise at agreeing with councillor
kettle there is a
remarkable amount of unanimity here on
the fact that
we really are between a rock and a hard
place
we've ended up in a position where we
are the fourth most effective district
council as a result of covid
and to say that that has focused our
minds as a cabinet
on what we're going to do and how we are
going to hopefully make progress
would be an understatement we've worked
incredibly hard
um i know i would say that wouldn't i
but i certainly
don't feel i've stopped in the last 12
months because of covid and because of
looking at this um i would like to say
that in response to those who said they
haven't really had much time
um the cabinet papers i can't tell you
precisely which day you would have
received them and they were published
but i have them sitting in front of me
and that cabinet was the 9th of february
with the detail of this
in so if you were preparing for
full council and were reading the
cabinet papers you would have had them
um by that date at the absolute latest
why now well this is about
leadership and about us actually doing
something that may not be comfortable it
may not be what everybody wants but
actually it's the best thing
as counselor cargill has said for
our residents and that's who we are
putting first and i would
just like to make the point given that i
represent um in another place the
deepest south
of the county that actually the rural
patch
in a super district would be represented
better
than it is at the moment in terms of
county level stuff where as councillor
wardy hoggins has mentioned
nobody knows where little compton is um
a point was made about about staff and
taking staff along
um and there has been a left from unison
the staff understand they are being
consulted
they understand the way that local
government is going and what we are
up against and that's both here and at
warwick that that has been going on
finally um this is the beginning
it's not the end other colleagues have
said that
but this is the beginning of the process
um the secretary of state i can assure
you
if and when we get to the point of
sending a letter
says you haven't done any consultation
go back and do it we're never going to
get there
so of course consultation comes in
the next stage and that's what we're
working up to so i would
commend the work and this approach
to the council and ask that you all
support it thank you
[Applause]
thank you councillor barker councillor
fielding next but i will remind
members chat is to be used to indicate
that you wish to speak
and for no other reason please
councillor fielding thank you chairman
um just to reassure both
um councillor barcrants and councillor
wally hoggins
little compton was in the telegraph on
the week over the weekend but there you
go
um we've been talking about
this amalgamation and i've raised it
with my parishes
for some years through the district
council
it's been raised at um
council meetings and other meetings so
we're not exactly being
pushed into this we're only jumping
or being jumped into this because of the
work of
the county when trying to get
a unification that we don't want so that
is the the pressure point
of trying to raise it and sort it out
now
we didn't realize that kerwig was around
the corner 18 months ago
we don't know what's going to be around
the corner next week
next month so we've got an opportunity
here
to give it a lot of thought or come
through with a lot of
questions and answers that will be
answered because they've got to be
answered
in the future so i'm i as i've said
before
to at osc on wednesday that
i'm supporting this because it is
important
that we get first of all we need to have
a timeline so that we know
when things are going to happen and when
we've got some more facts and figures
then we can hold the referendum bearing
in mind of course that
in 2023
we're all out for election so or maybe
2024 depending on
how things pan out but our councillors
are parishioners and can then
make their voices heard and we will then
have to put something forward
um in order to brief them as to what
what we're doing and what we're
supporting
so i'm in favor of it and therefore
i will leave it at that point but i do
agree with
uh my next-door neighbors uh
kettle barker
uh um rock uh all good counsellors of
hard work and
long time who worked longer in this than
i have
anyway thank you thank you councillor
fielding
uh councillor richards next please thank
you chairman
i must admit i've been wrestling with
this uh proposal for some time
um last year the council were asked
to decide on whether we should explore a
business case of merging the two
councils that i believe was unanimously
agreed if it wasn't unanimous it
certainly was a majority vote and we've
gone ahead and done that we have since
received the deloitte
report which bears out the pros and cons
the benefits
and the risks clearly from that there
are benefits to be had
and there are risks to be managed what
we're being asked to do today
is vote on the principle of further
exploration
exploring to get further information we
as a council is individuals
cannot make a definitive decision on
merging two councils until we have that
information
but we can't get that information
unless we as a council we as members of
that council
give authority give a mandate to our
leader
our executive and the cabinet in order
to be able to further explore and and
glean
that information we do
have in essence a safety net
in that within this document it clearly
states any final decision
must go to the public for consultation
that is in effect
a referendum it also must come back
through this council for us as members
to confirm yes or no whether we do or
don't want
to complete a merger i liken it almost
to
the uh a referendum that we had
nationally i don't want to draw out the
that too much but we voted on a
as an as a as a nation we voted on a yes
or a no and in or and out the four years
that preceded that
there have been unmeasurable amounts of
frustration and irritation by the
members of the public
by saying well that's not what we voted
on at the start we didn't have that
information at the start
well we don't have that information now
but we're looking to get
it and once we've got it we can then
make a definitive decision
so we have that safety net of a public
consultation and we have the safety net
of
coming back through council if
as has been proposed by our friends uh
in the
the council chamber if we were looking
to delay
simply that's kicking the can down the
road it avoids taking a difficult
decision
now we were elected to make difficult
decisions
and that's something we must do we have
an opportunity to do that
today personally i will be voting for
this
i understand other people's uh
reticence at voting now but we are as i
say here to make difficult decisions we
have an opportunity to do that
to get more information and it will come
back so please do vote for it now
give our leader our cabinet our
executive the mandate
to get the information that we're all
talking about that we all need
so that we can make the decision at the
right time in the future
thank you very much jim thank you
councillor richards
uh councillor pertiguella please
thank you chair um so if local
government reform is coming
and if the alternative to a merger or to
our own
stratfor district council is a single
workshop unitary
then i can see that the south
warwickshire district
precarso to a south workshop unitary
will benefit
the world i represent more than a large
remote
unitary geographically remote
i understand we're voting today for
exploring the possibility
of this vision however i want to be
reassured that my residence will be
fully and properly consulted
and that the elected members of this
district will be fully briefed
and will be able to input in this vision
and subsequent implementation program in
particular i have concerns about the
democratic deficit
with the proposed reduction of
counselors council tax alignment
and i know that my residents will want
planning decisions to remain
local i also want to know how these
changes will affect my parish councils
so that they can be also consulted in a
meaningful way
and most support parish councils will
have going forward
um and i also want to say that i would
have expected that such an important
decision about the future of our council
would have involved all councilors from
the outset
thank you thank you councillor
together uh councillor shenton nix
please
thank you mr chairman um a number of uh
of speakers of uh have talked about
residents
not being informed um and yet
throughout uh quite a few other speakers
and throughout the
the consultations throughout the
documents we talk about the golden
thread if you like
of consultation all the way through this
our residents will be kept informed
there is no question about that
i don't understand why this one keeps
keeps coming up
to pick up some of the other points that
have been made
um i mean councillor cleve said this
should not be a political game
i agree totally it shouldn't be a
political game it should be
based on on common sense on leadership
all these sorts of things counselor rock
makes a an excellent point in my opinion
and that this is the preparatory work
and and forgive me
cancer rock if i'm paraphrasing a little
bit but you said
this is preparatory work and we're not
making the full decision now
we are going to find out about these
things
and certainly that's what we're talking
about the vision
unless we find out we can't
go any further last week
we had a a session with deloitte's where
all members were invited along to that
and they could raise any questions they
like
uh and a number and and within that
there was a lot of talk about the
benefits
uh such as fitting in with government
policy able to deal
better able to deal with uh issues
mitigating financial challenges
and there's a whole list of them and i i
i listed them all at the time
and these are some of the reasons why we
should
look to explore this further i i think
you know members should
be assured that residents parish
councils
everyone involved in this all
stakeholders will be fully informed
there's no question about that and as
councillor cargill points out
the financial plan is linked with
developing
uh this vision and that's what it is a
vision
and we should move forward thank you mr
chairman
councillor trenton thank you very much
indeed uh the next
speaker i have is councillor mills
thanks mr chairman thank you um very
interesting
uh debate uh so far and i have to say i
have been wrestling with this one
um on overview and scrutiny we we raised
a lot of um
questions there um i think maybe taking
people by surprise but
looking at this i i will be voting for
it
but it's and and it is a start uh
we've got to start somewhere um but i
think the major thing is i'll be very
brief that
we must consult our residents i i've
been telling our parents my parish
councils that we will be
um looking at this at the full council
meeting
and i'm sure they're waiting baited
breath see what the decision is but
um it is a difficult one a a major major
decision we've got to make
um i will be voting this as i say but
um there's probably still a lot of
questions to be answered so
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you councillor mills
councillor jennings please okay
thank you chairman and i'll be really
quick because i think most of the points
have already been covered
creating a unique authority was brought
up at our parish meeting nearly a year
ago so
it's been knocking around um county
fired the starting gun on this
um we're behind them and we have to try
and
move quickly to try and catch up and
this is probably going to take about
four years or so with
and there'll be plenty of time for
consultation and i don't think now is
the time to dither or sit
sit on the fence today's vote is about
agreeing to put on our running shoes and
actually taking the first step
so i hope we're all going to go ahead
and vote with this
thank you councillor jennings uh that in
actual fact is the full list of
councillors have indicated obviously
we've still got the proposer councillor
uh jefferson and council of pemberton
who seconded the
uh motion uh reserved his position to
speak
but i believe councillor parker might
have a point of order that she'd like to
raise
and possibly uh council of roth an
amendment
uh so first i'll ask councillor barker
thank you councillor dixon and it was
simply a point of information
that um we did presentations by cabinet
at least
six months ago to the groups um i was
just
filming out what i said about the 9th of
february as well so just for information
thank you
that's thank you councillor parker uh
councillor ralph did you have an
amendment to put
no thank you thank you councillor ralph
uh that does signify better for us
counselor darren pemberton please uh as
the
second of the motion you reserved your
right to speak towards the end thank you
thank you chair um members this has been
a full wide-ranging and intelligent
debate
which does show us in a good light
in a positive light to our residents
that the difficult questions
are being asked
council wally hoggins is implacably
opposed to
this the beginning of this journey and
that is an honorable position and with
all due respect i accept that
um and again with respect uh we agree to
differ on that
council o'donnell ably supported by
many other members has quite rightly
set the bar very high in terms of
the duty on us to consult
with our residents our staff
our members and all of the other
stakeholders
who would be impacted upon this
proposal in should we get to it
because it has to be remembered we are
agreeing to embark on a journey which
will take us some three to four years
um consultation is a little like consent
it is at its best when it is informed
and it is right that our residents
should have the opportunity to be
consulted
in an informed basis and where we stand
at the moment
is that in some respects there are more
questions than there are answers
particularly around council tax
harmonisation
and democratic deficit i share members
concerns about the potential to have
wards
or you know you know with 59 members
would be in my opinion too big we're on
the same page in a lot of these things
but we need
to work those problems through come to
solutions
and to then place in front of the
residents an informed
package for them to give their consent
or not and this will be mirrored because
we have to remember we're not acting in
isolation
uh across warwick district as well
they will have the same questions to ask
they will have the same
level of consultation to uh to undergo
so i would urge members to look at the
strategic
to look at the question of
embarking on the journey and a number of
members have expressed
concern that they feel
that they have not been consulted early
enough in the process
and it is always a balance about
bringing anything
forward when you get to where do you get
to the position where there's something
formed enough to start to
to consult upon and counselor barca does
rightly highlight that there have been
various
presentations but members just need to
listen very carefully because this is
something that does not happen
very often i'm going to apologize
okay i accept and myself
and the leader have had discussions with
the leader of the opposition and
her deputy and we accept the point that
is made
about the feeling of all members not
being
involved early enough um it wasn't a
game councillor cleve absolutely not
this is too important to play games and
most of you know me well enough to know
that i'm not bright enough to play games
so i'm accepting what you say but please
please do not let a feeling of
slight color your decision
about what is best for our residents and
what is best for our residents
is to embark on this journey to
understand
what we have to do in terms of looking
for the best
future and then to be in a position to
debate it fully and put it to our
residence
and i i see the chairman scratching his
ear which seems to suggest i'm getting
near the end is that correct
and finally although there isn't
amendment why now we
we we have to have the bandwidth to do
other things than the immediate recovery
but covid's recovery impacts will
stretch
years to come and there is the potential
when we be
if we come together to be a much
more uh to have much better
opportunities
to fight and bid for for um
revenue also revenue from bids from
central government as a south
warwickshire
entity than we might on our own so why
now because there are lots of
opportunities to grab
and it does fit in with covered recovery
um so members i would urge you all
to vote in favor of embarking on this
journey
there are con this the the leader and i
have committed
uh to ensure that there is a robust and
regular update
process with the leader of the liberal
group and her deputy
but that will be alongside everything we
do with members
and the public and i really do i see the
eyebrows up on the chair so i really
must stop
thank you thank you councillor pemberton
uh i now call on councillor jefferson as
the proposer of the motion
to round it all up and then we will go
to a vote
thank you that's the jefferson thank you
chair
uh a very interesting debate
excuse me can i be absolutely clear
what we're deciding on today is
a vision a strategy and a direction of
travel
there is an awful lot more work to do
and if i listen to the questions that
have been asked and the points that have
been raised
actually a lot of them we can't answer
until that work is done and in reality
consultation until we've done an awful
lot of that work
we can consult on the principle but as
we have had today
there'll be a lot of questions that we
need to have done a lot more work
to actually be able to answer there is a
long way to go
what i would also pick up on is
the timing and the urgency
the reality actually is that
the timing is not necessarily under our
control
the government have already asked three
councils to submit plans that was
before kovid really hit
but there is no doubt in my mind that
the government will move fast
once it moves county council has
actually submitted
a proposal as has been said
they did it without consultation and
without involvement
and they forced it through so they've
set the pace
we cannot afford to wait we are between
a rock and a hard place
and we are doing the best we can under
those circumstances
i understand the point about kobe but
covert is going to last a long time
we have in my view to act
now we need to be in control of our own
destiny
we definitely do
why are we looking at combining
districts
well that's very simple combining
districts
is something that is under our control
a unitary that will depend on the white
paper
that will come from the government
so at the moment they
uh intention to actually create
a super district should be seen
as a step on the road to a south
warwickshire unitary
let's be absolutely clear that's the
direction of travel
that's where we want to go our view is
it is best for our residents and it's
the best future we can have
now the work that needs to be done
will flesh all that out as people have
been saying today there are a lot of
issues
we don't have the answers to because the
work needs to be done
i will go right back to what i said at
the beginning
what we're deciding on today is a vision
a strategy
and a direction of travel and it will
mean a lot more work is done
and i've already made a commitment to
make sure there is consultation
and there is involvement of the liberal
democrats
and then as we get more answers we can
do more consultation
and involvement with residents so
i urge you to vote for
all the recommendations one to nine
thank you
thank you council jefferson right
we'll shortly go to the vote on that one
and i'll ask mr buckland to uh
to take a re do a roll call as such
um it's not often that the chairman
makes other comment
but i note that uh seven councillors uh
who are here today uh digital as such
have not spoken
which basically means that uh the vast
majority without a shadow of a doubt
have contributed to an excellent debate
um as to public consultation
this morning i posted the details of
this meeting on three facebook pages
and whether our audience is any greater
than usual i do not know
uh but i'll find that out when i get
home and look at my facebook
uh so mr buckland i'll ask you to
start a roll call uh starting with
myself
for in favor of
thank you chairman to remind council
voted in relation to minute
538 the recommendations from from
cabinet so when i call your name if you
could please
indicate whether you're you put your
name in whether you're voting for
against or abstaining in relation to the
proposal
um chairman council councillor dixon
catherine dixon four thank you
councillor
council fitter for
thank you counselor adam councillor adam
four newcastle clock
council [ __ ] four
thank you councillor barker
councillor barker four councillor
plumbing
councillor bravid very tentative for
thank you cargill council cargill iv
thank you councillor cleve councillor
cleve
four thank you um councillor curtis
apologies uh councillor curtis for
reluctantly
thank you councillor eden councillor
for thank you councillor fielding
councillor fielding4 thank you thanks
for
thank you councillor ian frenchly
thank you councillor harris councillor
harris for
thank you harvey councillor harvey four
thank you castle henshaw seraphin andrew
serafin
four thank you council jefferson
councillor jefferson four thank you
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall four
thank you councillor kettle that's the
kettle
for thank you council mills
council mills for thank you council
o'donnell councillor donald four
thank you councillor parry councillor
parry for
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor pemberton
four thank you councillor keller
councillor tagalog 4 thank you
councillor richards
councillor richards four thank you
councillor riley
council riley four new councillor rock
chancellor rock four thank you council
of wolf
councillor ralph a very reluctant four
thank you councillor shenton councillor
shenton four
thank you councillor hoggins councillor
wally hoggins against
thank you chairman there were 34 votes
in favor and one against thank you
thank you david uh we've now been uh
sat down for very nearly two hours i'm
going to call a
five-minute comfort break
welcome back everybody um hopefully uh
you feel a bit more comfortable now i
certainly do
uh so moving on now to agenda item
eight which is the continuation of the
revised
sill installment policy until the 31st
of october
2021 and i invite councillor pemberton
as a deputy leader of the council to
introduce
this item councilor pemberton thank you
very much
chair um i should try and keep this as
brief as i possibly can
members will recall that arising out of
the
impacts of the pandemic and the
consequent impacts on the construction
industry
a decision was made to
vary the installment arrangements for
large
scale seal
payments and this merely seeks
council's agreements to extend that
current policy to
the 31st of october with the hope that
the construction industry will have
embarked on its recovery to the extent
that we will be able to return to the
original
um sil installments regime from november
the 1st
important to remind members that this
does not actually
do anything other than change the
schedule of sill payments it does not
mean
any um reduction in the amount of sill
that is collected
so members the recommendation is that
the revised seal installments policy
uh established in july be continued
until the 31st of october and revert
then to the original 2018 policy from
the first of november happy to take any
questions but really hopeful that
we can we can all agree to this fairly
fairly straightforwardly thank you chair
thank you councillor pemberton uh the
proposal having been made by councillor
pemberton i call upon a second to please
is indicating the chat
councillor jefferson you've indicated
that you will second this can you
put that verbally please
i second the recommendation chair
i'll just see if anybody's indicated
that wish to speak other than that we'll
assume that it has
the agreement of counsel
nothing has appeared in the chat and
therefore that uh
proposal is agreed we now move through
to agenda item
nine the calling procedure to consider a
report that outlines options to revert
to the pre-covered 19 procedures
call-ins
and to make permanent the restriction of
the call into the key decisions
and i invite councillor jefferson to
introduce the title
uh thank you chair
this is about uh making the procedure
for callings referred to the pre-march
2020 process
uh applicable callings considered at a
meeting of the osc
and members consider whether to make
permanent the restrictions of calling
to key decisions and i
i'm in favor of these recommendations
and
i would just say that uh in conjunction
with this there will be
far more pre-decision scrutiny and we've
already set up
meetings between the chief executive
myself
and the chair of osc to go through the
forward agenda
uh and i noticed that uh
the chair of ursi wishes to speak and i
defer to her
thank you leader i'm reassured by the
commitment to the regular meetings
that's a
positive step forward to pre-decision
scrutiny thank you for that
um and i would just also like to ask for
commitment
from the council leader that key
decision criteria is reviewed on an
annual basis to just make sure we keep
it all up to date and relevant to where
we will be at that moment in time
uh thank you council o'donnell i have
no problems whatsoever in agreeing to
that
thank you thank you councillor jefferson
i see that uh council junior
and i'll the council of pemberton has
indicated which the second
council of june head first yes the the
calling procedures
uh are used to ensure that where there
are legitimate concerns
about having a decision uh how our
decision was taken
it it isn't um where there is a
political decision
it has always been it's never really
been a it's never been abused by this
council
i would welcome a stronger predecision
scrutiny
and on balance i would not welcome a
formal restriction on call-ins
to the key executive decisions uh as
outlined to restrict this would be to
restrict democracy
and i would request a separate vote on
this matter thank you
chairman you're muted side chairman
council of june we need your proposal
that we have a
vote uh seconded do you have a second
day for that
uh i believe i do yep
count slipper together would you like to
second uh
councillor june ed's proposal yes i
would like to second councillor jonette
proposal
thank you
in that case we will go to a recorded
vote on this issue
chairman before we do so can i just
clarify as i understand it i think point
one
of the recommendations is accepted by
council
unless i hear otherwise and i think it's
just purely point two
or asking council to record a vote in as
to
that at this point the key decisions are
remain
in relation to the um yeah that the
calling
is restricted to the key decisions only
and that's what we're voting for
at this point agree
councillor pemberton has asked to speak
to the amendment
uh i call therefore on councillor
pemberton first
thank you chair um i i understand
councillor junid's um concern
that um this could be seen as a way
of um corralling scrutiny
um it it is absolutely not that
i think one of those but i would uh
i'm actually advised that there's no
amendment been put it's merely a request
for recorded vote i apologize then if
that's
if it's not that as such then thank you
i shall i shall
i shall stop now thank you thank you
council pemberton
so it's a recording vote and i'll ask mr
butland to
carry that out please thank you chairman
so the vote is in relation to
whether to make permanent well to make
permanent restrictions in relation to
calling
is being restricted the key decision so
if you are full
against abstaining relation to the
recommendation that made
i'll start with councillor dixon
catholic dixon four
um councillor fitter council fitter four
thank you councillor adam councillor
adam against
iv
thank you councillor curtis anderson
curtis
against thank you councillor eden
council edin against thank you
councillor fielding
cancer fielding four thank you
councillor fleming
councillor
thank you councillor ian frenchly
councillor ian fragili
against thank you kendall jenny quenchly
cancel the journey fragility against
thank you councillor harris
councillor harris four thank you harvey
council harvey four thank you councillor
henshaw seraphin
and slahinsha seraphin against thank you
jefferson councillor jefferson for
[Music]
thank you councillor kendall councillor
kendall
four thank you councillor kettle
councillor kettle for thank you
councillor mills
council mills four thank you councillor
o'donnell
councillor donald four thank you
councillor harry
councillor parry for thank you
councillor pemberton
castle pemberton for thank you
councillor
angelo pertagella against
councillor richards for thank you
council o'reilly
councillor riley against thank you
rock councillor rock
against thank you that's the vote
council rolf against thank you council
against yenten for thank you i'm
councillor wally hoggins
councillor wally hoggins four thank you
chairman that was carried four um by um
20 votes to 13 with one extension oh
sorry
21st 14 with one abstention
thank you mr buckland so
item nine has been agreed i
now move to another uh
subject the council's budget
and agenda item 10. i
invite the leader of the council council
jefferson
and a representative from the liberal
democratic group to make statements to
the council
those statements are there's ten minutes
allowed for each of those statements
councillor jefferson thank you mr
chairman
i'm certainly not capable of speaking
for ten minutes this afternoon
uh this has been perhaps the most
challenging year imaginable
in which to set a budget we did think
that setting the budget for 2021 was
challenging
but said in this year's budget easily
surpassed those challenges
uh covered 19 has played havoc with our
finances
and the finances of other councils the
strength of our reserves has been a key
factor enabling us
to produce a budget that meets the
demanding requirements
of the section 151 officer
locally kovit 19 is seriously undermined
our successful
and prosperous economy this will fade
through to our tax receipts
and give us added challenges we've been
due to have the benefit of a four-year
settlement review for three years
running
events have made us wait for yet another
year
we still need to know what the
government intends to do about the
future of
business retention and it's possible
reform
the impact of curving 19 on the high
street has made a review
more urgent we've been saying for some
years that the new homes bonus
which has been a massive support to our
budget will disappear
it's now clear that it will whatever
comes out of the next four years
spending review
always assuming we actually get one
three things are predictable
first that whatever government decides
district councils
are likely to receive less second
there'll be an increasing need for the
cost of local government
district level to be met locally third
central government is reluctant to bail
out councils in financial difficulty
and only does so as a last resort
though we've been able to produce a
budget that preserves services in 2021
and enables us to meet the minimum level
of reserves the section 151
officer believes are the minimum
necessary of the five years of the
medium-term financial
strategy is i think quite remarkable
we're also proposing in working much
more closely with warwick district
council
and aiming towards a south warwickshire
council
we aim to put in place a strategy to
offset longer-term budget pressures
the long-term soundness of the council's
financial position
is the bedrock of its ability to meet
our residents expectations
the budget proposals before us are
designed to do just that
we face challenging circumstances
head-on
made tough decisions and produced a
sustainable budget
my colleague councillor trevor harvey
will provide more details
under the next agenda item thank you
chair
thank you councillor jefferson uh
councillor junaid on behalf of the
liberal democratic group
yes uh post this crisis one of the
things we have to concentrate on
is long-term growth and efficiency we
have to
concentrate on measures that contribute
to longer-term economic growth
that attracts investment and is
supportive of business
but also the services of our residents
affordable housing and low carbon
generation regeneration have to play a
part
balancing economic growth and
sustainability
we have to face up to the fact that the
way the government is going
is they are awarding funds on a bidding
basis rather than directly to local
authority more and more
and we have to look at how we can
support our officers
to assist them in doing that in putting
forward successful bids
we have to also look very much more
towards a partnership approach
to assist in improving town centers and
in supporting
innovation climate change has to be part
of the budget
and we want to be able to make sure that
communities are carried with us that
we're not doing things to communities
that communities are allowed to show
that the
innovation that they have can deliver
changes
in their communities and along along
there we
we also have to address some very
difficult issues that are in this budget
uh after this uh budget we must have
some more serious debate
about some of the alternatives that are
being put forward
if government funding does not come
forward
there are some very very difficult
issues that are in this budget
that are really not acceptable to
residents
and i want to make sure and that we have
further investigation
into these items i will look uh and
address some of these
items in more depth at the next stage of
this
at this budget debate
thank you councillor today uh i'll now
uh as the chairman move
the following that council procedural
rule
15.5 which when a councillor may speak
again
be waived to allow one nominated member
from each group to speak
more than once on the budget-related
items
if anybody is against the usual
procedure of waiving that particular
rule
can they please indicate if you do not
speak
or indicated in the chat then obviously
that rule is waived
i'm advised that i need a second for my
proposal that
council procedural rule 15.5 is waived
for now
so perhaps uh councillor jefferson could
you oblige
chair i will oblige i will second your
proposal
thank you very much indeed sorry for
that uh in my uh
my notes uh so now that uh we have
the opportunity to have one speaker each
group
speaking more than once i'm going to
make the
assumption is it uh councillor brum uh
juned
um to speak on behalf of the liberals
more than once
or are you delegating that elsewhere
counsellor no i'm going to speak on it
thank you councillor julia right uh
we'll now go through to the debate and i
see councillor bromwich
has been set as uh indicated first
council of bronze
yes so obviously we are well aware
about the problems kobe has caused to
our district
we're well aware most of us that we are
forecast to be probably about the fourth
worst impacted economy within the
district and it does make for very tough
times when it comes to
setting a budget however i have some
concerns
within what is contained in this budget
so i started my first concern my first
concern having
been communicating with the 105 151
officer
was to find out that we were giving
staff a 1
pay increase which is above the
inflation rate which over the past year
has been between 0.2
and 0.7 percent well i do not dispute
i i do need to interrupt your capital
growth i'm sorry about that
um essentially we've moved in you're
moving through
onto item 11 and i'll call you after
that has been
introduced by council welcome yeah okay
we'll happily
hold off on that part there but yeah we
need to recognize we are in difficult
times
in this budget certainly and we need to
so we'll we'll move through to council
harvey to introduce
uh the agenda item 11 and then i will be
calling upon yourself early on
okay councillor harvey uh thank you
chairman
at the end of march last year this
council's general reserve fund
stood at 8.9 million pounds
at the end of march this year this
figure is estimated will be reduced to
4.7 million pounds
our general reserve fund will have been
halved in a single year
this has been the effect of kovid 19 on
this council's finances
over the past 12 months the british
economy has suffered its most pronounced
recession within the last
300 years the government has borrowed
record amounts
in peacetime of approaching 400 billion
to finance support programs
targeted at individuals and businesses
the government's capacity to borrow in
relation to the economy's capability to
finance
and ultimately to repay its debts is not
infinite
the overdue spending review has been
delayed now for the last three years
until the terms of that spending group
review are announced later this year
this council's ability to plan its
finances with any
great degree of certainty remains
hamstrung
by the prospects for the uk's economy by
the prospects for the district's future
businesses
and for the prosperity of our residents
the acid test for the finances of this
council
is the level of its reserves over the
five-year period
of the medium-term financial strategy
unless it can be shown that the minimum
level of reserves
set by the section 151 officer of two
and a half million pounds can be
maintained
both throughout this period and above
this level
any such budget proposals would not be
viable
the section one five officer would
simply not approve them
the budget proposals before council
today do essentially
two things first they protect the
council's ability to provide its
residents with the range
and quality of the services they
currently enjoy for the forthcoming
financial year second despite the need
for some painful decisions in the
subsequent four years
the proposed budget demonstrates that
the necessary minimum level of reserves
can be maintained throughout the period
although they will nevertheless
decline to close to 2.7 million pounds
the pain of calling upon residents to
meet the implications
of the dramatic reduction in the
council's reserves
has been reduced significantly by the
proposal
to move some elements of the reserves
previously earmarked
to support other projects and to
reallocate them to the general reserve
fund
similarly part of the adjustment strain
has been taken within the organization's
cost structure
by for example leaving a number of posts
vacant by budgeting to share some costs
with warwick district council
and through a number of joint senior
appointments shared with
warwick inevitably however some of the
strain will need to fall on the
residents
of the district this will principally be
in three ways first by an increasing
of five pounds in the level of council
tax on a band d property
second by the introduction of the
results of a review of car parking
charges
by the level of inflation last increased
nine years ago
third by the implementation of the
decision taken last year
and subsequently postponed for a year to
activate
the garden waste scheme
these last two proposals have given rise
into comment
and liberal democrat opposition
i'd like to put the consequences of not
taking these decisions
into their financial context if the
council's car park charges
were not revised as proposed and
everything else was held constant
the council's reserves would fail the
section 151 officers
two and a half million pound reserved
test by year three
of the period of the medium-term
financial strategy
and by the end of the fifth year the
council's reserves
would be negative by 1.6 million that is
4.1 million pounds lower than the
required
threshold if on the other hand the
decision concerning the garden waste
scheme
was not to have been activated a scheme
that all
11 liberal democrat members
and the independent members for clopton
and southam north
opposed last year in a roll call vote
called for by the member for tiddington
and everything else were to be held
constant the section
one five officers reserves test would
again be failed
in the third year of the median term
financial strategy
the reserves at the end of the five-year
period would as a result be
2.3 million pounds negative in other
words
a decision not to introduce the garden
waste scheme
everything else held constant would lead
to the council's reserves
being 4.8 million pounds below the
required minimum
by the end of the five-year term of the
medium-term financial strategy
of course if the liberal democrats were
to maintain their opposition
to both the change to car park charges
and to the introduction of the garden
waste scheme everything else held
constant
the combined effect would be that much
greater
the council's minimum reserve position
would barely be intact
after only two years and by the end of
the five-year period
of the medium-term financial strategy
the council's reserves
would be negative to the tune of some
6.6
million pounds leaving the general fund
reserves
9.1 million pounds below the minimum
required level the question then would
be
which fees and which charges would the
liberal democrats want to increase to
close the gap
which of the council service budgets
would the liberal democrats
choose to slash to fill the gap and by
how much
how many forced staff redundancies would
the liberal democrats
need to make to produce a balanced
budget
like it or not the review of the
council's car park
charges and the introduction of the
garden waste scheme
are both integral to the health
coherence
and financial integrity of the budget
proposals put forward today
in bringing forward these budget
proposals the conservative group is
facing
reality and acting responsibly
if the liberal democrats either vote
against these proposals
or abstain they will be demonstrating to
the residents of the district
again that they fail to understand the
consequences
of their own policies and they are more
interested in political posturing and
grandstanding
than dealing with the realities of life
producing this budget has been a team
effort
i'd like to place on record my thanks to
members of the covid recovery action
group
to those members of the business
community and to those residents
who contribute to the feedback processes
to my colleagues within the cabinet and
the conservative group
and in particular to the work of george
hill our section 151 officer
and all the members of the finance
department team who have been
so supportive i invite members therefore
to approve the proposals that the budget
for 2021-22
has set out in the papers and have
pleasure in proposing the recommendation
to this effect to counsel thank you
chairman
thank you council harvey i now need that
uh
proposal seconding before i uh read out
the further comment
can i ask for a second to please
council of pemberton
thank you second and uh
that was very weak but i did just hear
you second that proposal
uh i now have a formal statement to read
i need to inform the meeting that in
accordance with the local authorities
standing orders england amendment
regulations 2014
a recorded vote will be taken on the
revenue and capital budgets 21
22. so that is
my advice and information to you it's
not a recorded vote at this time it will
be a recorded vote
at the end of the debate so uh
the debate having been opened by
councillor harvey
the proposals having been made back
outside and seconded
i think council bromwich will be the
first to speak
councillor brumbich yeah so as we were
saying earlier and now getting in the
right place
obviously we appreciate that we've had
very difficult times
indeed as part of the council action
recovery group and that
we've been i've probably been one of the
most
pessimistic of the councillors in that
group regarding finances
i do have some concerns on this budget
at the moment because obviously we are
proposing about a three and a half
percent
increase my first concern
is that we are proposing to increase
staff pay
by one percent when the average for
inflation rate over the past year has
been between point
two to point seven percent this is not
to do the staff at this service we've
worked so hard in coving
by i am struggling to justify an above
inflation increase to residents within
this district
many of whom have spent the past year on
furlough
and many of whom have lost their jobs i
actually think it would have been a more
i i still think it'd be a more
reasonable option
that for this year that we should
actually introduce
a one-year only pay freeze for all
staff on that that's actually the staff
increase comes to around about 120
000 pounds in this budget according to
the 151
officer and i said i just cannot justify
at the moment supporting a staff
increase on that
there's some of a little observation
note on this
so at the council recovery group
meetings we discussed
about the manned reception at elizabeth
house
and we did have discussions about the
potential scrapping that
that's 250 000 pounds plus 30 000 pounds
for security staff
can we really justify this when no other
places across the district now have
manned receptions
whatsoever and i note that council rov
when i bought this
up in a council recovery meeting said
well the older folks in stratford like
to go in to see a receptionist
but then so did the older folks in
southern before we moved to a contact
point
and no doubt other areas across the
district
we have to be a bit realistic here and
say is it a luxury
we can continue to afford that 300
000 pounds based on the figures
approximately 300 000 pounds
based on the figures that the 151
officer gave me
would take one pound off our five pound
base
now that's worth thinking about because
the figures he gave me
was for every one pound we reduced and
that that's a 305 000
reduction in income that just think
about that counsellors
for that having the privilege of having
a reception rather than a contact point
that we've seriously got to think
whether it's a luxury we can afford
as our belts are tightening and probably
are going to get squeezed more over the
longer term
now i believe we can actually go further
on savings
in general such as the reams of paper
which i get through my door about
council
about council meetings cabinet meetings
various committee meetings
which were also emailed to me now
it could just we can justify scrapping
that
both in terms of costs and environmental
damage and that
i think it's something we need to be
looking at as we go
forward now and done sooner rather than
later
i cite other areas where we could be
looking to save money
for instance i just recently renewed my
private hire license
so i have to download the pdf form print
it out
fill it in and send it all back and what
could be a proper online form and
actually
be done far more efficiently luckily i'm
technically enough savvy
to actually edit that pdf form online
but not everybody has that ability
and we could streamline services such as
license applications
that and we should be looking to do that
at the moment i mean we have not
i've not seen any outline proposals that
we are looking to do that
as cost-saving measures but all these
small amounts do mount up
in the longer term that and we need to
be looking at that
we also need to be looking at ways that
we look to generate
additional revenue so before christmas
the chancellor announced a fund
for local authorities to apply for
grants for
projects we should be looking probably
at putting things like applications in
for reverse vending machines for
recycling purposes
which would generate the council money i
accept we're not going to be able to
fund that as a council but maybe we
should be looking to bring that in
as a grant as grant application money
now
we should also then be looking at the
purpose of venture house
and the long muted venture house 2 in
south which hasn't
come about we need to build thank you
organizations like venture house to
actually complete
to be able to continue on
10 seconds yeah and
overall we need to be having serious
questions about
where we are spending and where we are
going to be saving money
both now and in the future thank you
very much indeed
councillor juned i believe you wish to
put the lib dem
amendment on the budget over to yourself
councillor junaid
thank you can i start by saying that the
lib dems have
and will continue to do our job which is
to question
and scrutinize all budget decisions to
ensure that they are properly
stress tested because if we do not ask
our questions
then things decisions can go through
without proper
uh scrutiny with that without asking the
difficult questions
we do need that scrutiny and that is a
part of a
democratic process which we will
continue to
to uphold and continue with
we also need to stress and highlight the
role of government in not adequately
funding
local government in the way that they
said they would do at the beginning of
this covet
crisis and it is time that
all of us said government that they must
fund local government adequately
our budget is based upon two things that
we think are absolutely crucial going
forward
one is to ensure that there is proper
economic
recovery from covet 19.
we do need to bring into the council and
get working
with the council a great deal more work
in improving our town centers extra
economic development expertise
making sure that we are able to bid for
government funding
unfortunately that is the way that
government funding is going it is going
it is being awarded on a bidding basis
and it's a very specialized process
our offices are excellent but it
requires
experience and knowledge and it does
mean that
uh council officers end up taking uh
spending a lot of time on them
when they are needed to put their
expertise to work
elsewhere in the work of the council
so we do need to make sure that we are
attracting those external grants
in order that our town centres recover
and that our communities recover we
cannot to just rely
upon businesses being able to do it for
themselves because a lot of them are
struggling at this moment
the other element of our bid about our
budget
is using a sum of money that is already
ring fenced in last year from last year
in the climate change fund
what we want to do is to make sure that
communities
are fully involved in finding solutions
for the uh for commun forum
climate change that we are able to
harness the
innovation that is undoubtedly there
with our communities
we want to make sure that that they need
the means to address climate change
is not being done to people but is done
by communities themselves that we are
allowing
innovation to come from communities and
change to become from communities
uh and i think there is a lot there that
we can do so we're not
introducing a new fund we're introducing
a different way
of using the existing fund
the 500 000 that has been in the
community change
fund for a year with very little of it
being spent
we want to be able to show how the
community show us
how to change and that they will be
harnessed
in delivering and we want that we are
harnessing the energy of our communities
now along with our budget lines we want
to stress that further investigation is
carried out
on alternatives because we do like to
make sure that we've asked
all the questions about increasing
parking charges
over 65's parking permits where and
where
further income could be sought that
we've asked the questions about
affordable housing
and that we have fought and sat found
other ways of dealing with affordable
housing
this council is asked not in this budget
but afterwards
to revisit previous proposals on ways to
develop housing
and also examine best practice in other
local councils
and finally we support the work done by
our own officers
on addressing homelessness and support
more work to be
ensure that more people are housed and
not
put into unsuitable temporary
accommodation
and given the support needed however we
have not included these
in the budget lines at the moment
because we feel that that is a debate
for afterwards
and that we want all people all our
counsellors to be involved in that
so our budget concentrates two on two
areas
one is business support and the other is
the community climate change fund
thank you i think you councillor june ed
uh i see that councillor curtis has
indicated that he will
second your proposed amendment uh
councillor curtis
yes i would like to speak but also at
this stage
chair should i just second the amendment
your decision councilor curtis you can
either reserve your position
and speak at the end of the debate on
the amendment or
speak now but you don't get the
opportunity as it were to speak
twice sorry i will get the opportunity
to speak twice
well you you can you can
you can second you can you can second
the proposal now and reserve your
position to speak at the end or you can
thank you very much for that
clarification thank you
councillor pemberton please
thank you thank you chair um i'll i'll
speak to
uh the amendment um i would also like if
i may to make a comment on
councillor bromage's uh uh speech
um the the liberal democrats
um have put forward two proposals the
first
is in essence uh an economic uh
development officer
we all accept the need to
play our part to support the recovery
from covid and also to ensure that our
high streets can face the existential
threat
posed by online shopping
i think the proposition is perhaps
founded on a misunderstanding
in that there is a feeling that this
council has missed out on opportunities
i think that goes back to a grant
application in 2019
um that uh we missed out on uh stratfor
town
didn't fit the criteria and it doesn't
matter how good a bid writer you are
and i'm quite a good bid writer if you
don't fit the criteria you're not going
to get through
and studly's scheme was not felt to have
passed
and you can't win them all since the
recover
since the pandemic members will be aware
that we have secured funds through the
lep
for the riverside project and the
officers in this council are adept at
putting forward
um good bids and we will be successful
in the future
it's a hundred thousand pounds over two
years um
sounds a lot of money but it probably
nets down to somebody on about 35k
a year which is not a really
high-powered high-flying
economic development guru
if we were going to be looking at
anything and it would be far more
effective to
potentially employ a bid writer for a
specific piece of work
that would be more cost effective and
would be a better approach
and it would be the approach that i
would favor um
the uh other item that uh councillor
junior talks about
is the 100 000 pounds and as unless i
miss my mark entirely this is entirely
in the gift of the climate change panel
and if councillor junior were to bring
this forward through the climate change
panel
um if there is a way of spending that
money
effectively to meet our climate change
goals it seems inconceivable to me that
the climate change panel
wouldn't go down that route so there are
different ways to skin that
both of those particular cats um
i would make a point around the housing
around the question of affordable
housing um
councillor junior and i will you know
cancel jim will recall we have looked at
a housing company
at that particular time the finance
numbers didn't quite stack up
um we have through the housing
investment panel
sought ways to support additional
affordable housing
and particularly in relation to
homelessness
it is this administration's avowed
intention
that to all intents and purposes we
end rough sleeping in this district
and that's evidenced by our support for
the fred winter center
our support for purchasing move on
accommodation
and the recommendation that we support
the youth in place project
through still monies so i do think that
we are on the same lines there
i think that our budget achieves
everything
um that uh councillor unit is seeking
there are just different ways to do so
um so
on that basis uh i would be commending
our budget
final point cancer promise as far as i
understand it um
leaving aside the fact that i think we
should reward council staff who have
been at the forefront of the
the addressing of the pandemic they're
the people who've been
in the in the shielding center in the
leisure center issuing the food packs
they've been keeping the show on the
road they've been keeping homelessness
inquiries
done all the way through they've been
keeping this council serving as
residents
through the pandemic but as i understand
it this is
this is the pay rise negotiated
nationally so i don't as i understand it
think we have any latitude to uh to do
anything uh
around that and i would not be i would
not be supportive of anything
um that does not reward our staff you
know they are not the best paid people
in the world they are not hedge fund
managers
you know they they are ordinary people
doing an extraordinary job to support
our residents and i for one
um feel they're worth every penny and
would support him on that
and that's probably me done and i i will
happily commend and support
our budget uh to members thank you
thank you very much uh councillor
pemberton uh councillor rolfe is next i
would just uh
mention that at the present time we are
talking and debating the lib dem
amendment and that is
all we propose looking at at the present
time so we're speaking to the amendment
only
councillor rolfe uh thank you chair
um i just wanted to mention
um the uh pest control services
um i've done quite a lot of research on
this and it's something i think this
council should look at
um lancaster city council
their pest control services are called
unbugged
they have five star reviews um and
they're double award winners
um and the reason uh that
uh we've proposed this in our amendment
is that
um this is a way for our pest control
services to become a commercial
enterprise
um and to to actually tender
for all our local businesses within
stratford district
and further beyond but also keeping in
mind our residents
um we contender for
our services our pest control services
are exemplary
and we should we should um really look
to that
um and and i'm sure um i've done a lot
of research so if one of the officers
wants to talk to me about it i'm quite
happy to talk
to them about it um and i'm sure um
it's it's a way of increasing um
uh our income into this council over the
next uh period of the
um medium tram um um
well certainly the next five years and
beyond um
so um please ex
please accept one of the offices i'm
quite happy to discuss this
further i think it is a way for uh
income to be increased
thank you
thank you councillor rolf uh sorry for
that i a lost my camera b
lost my chat line etc but i
think councillor trenton is the next
person that's indicated to speak on this
one please
thank you mr chairman uh it's really
as much as anything a point of
clarification because
uh item four on their uh amendment
seeks to to wrap the car park charges
review as part of the transport plan
now i'm presuming this means the local
transport plan
that uh county actually drive in which
case
that's not due to be completed until
2022
which if we delayed uh the charges
until 2022 we would effectively
um be reducing the reserves
below the legal minimum of 2.5 million
and in which case our section 105
officer might have something to say
about that
and i'm curious is that seriously what
lib dems are proposing an illegal budget
thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor shenton
before i call councillor parry who's
indicated something in the chat
i'd just like to clarify that the
amendment in actual fact is a proposal
of an alternative budget
um so hopefully that clarifies
things for for all members uh councillor
parry have you uh
something to uh to add to the debate on
this amendment
yes i i just wanted to actually respond
to
councillor rolfe to to advise that
actually
stratfor district council does provide a
pest control
services um we do rats mice animal fleas
squirrels carpet beetles clothes moss
bed bugs
cockroaches garden ants bird control
wasps hornets we're already doing all of
that
um and and our offices are very highly
qualified
and we've if she'd like to look on the
website she will see
all the the costs associated with those
pest control services
and treatments that's all i have to say
thank you mr parry
i think that not seeing anybody else
wishing to speak
to this amendment as indicated
oh yes sorry sorry councillor curtis uh
you
seconded the amendment and delayed your
uh or
deferred your opportunity so here it is
sorry about that
thank you thank you david um yes um
first of all an answer to
councillor shenton's comment just now
we're certainly not proposing the lib
dems
in a legal budget and i would actually
like to thank
the section 151 officer george hill
for his support in helping prepare the
lib dems alternative budget
which is achievable it's financially
sound
and it does retain above the minimum
reserves over the period of the f
of the medium term financial plan so i
think we should just
clarify that for starters returning to
council
trevor harvey council trevor harvey
appears to be
running in the past and maybe that's
where he feels more comfortable i i
don't know
counselor trevor harvey is referring to
pre-covered debates and discussions
around budgets that we were having
whilst it may suit
his purposes to indulge in such
political grandstanding
it does not portray the reality of the
situation which the lib dems group
fully recognized has changed
since copied further lib then
believe that to ensure recovery
going forward we need
considered and prudent investment
that is absolutely essential
we look i'm sure we all look enviously
at our colleagues
in levington who received grant aid of
10 million pounds and
none eating of 13 million pounds and we
understand
that it is absolutely essential to be
able to attract such grant aid
unfortunately perhaps it's um escape
accounts of pemberton's
memory that um the bid from stratford
was
criticized i believe as lacking
imagination
this is no criticism at all
of the excellent work done by officers
at our council we all know how
incredibly hard they are working but
at this time we need the lib dems
believe
we need to make prudent additional
investment to ensure that we can
fully recover from this terrible period
so thank you very much chair
thank you councillor curtis and uh
apologies for uh
nearly uh omitting yourself um
uh i've now got a question for
councillor junid
uh as the liberal democratic
spokesperson
who able to speak more than once do you
want to add
anything to the amendment before we go
back to
councillor harvey who made the original
proposal
um so essentially councillor junior do
you wish to speak
at this time i think it has all been all
been said we this is a genuine um
constructive proposal that has been put
forward from us
we have tried not to um get into the
or the other background this was a
genuine way of trying to highlight those
areas that needed to be addressed
thank you thank you councillor june ed i
see councillor peter geller has uh
squeaked in uh the chat so we'll go to
council
for toguela before we go to councillor
harvey
uh council posed together thank you
chair um
i just wanted to um highlight or clarify
the the climate change fund this this is
the the budget is is the forum for it
because the climate change panel will
not have
doesn't have a decision-making um remit
uh i believe so he would have to come
back
to council anyway so the the climate
change fund
um is actually this is a forum to to
debate it
um and and to to you know put forward
something
that would help um a green recovery uh
from kovid but also
contribute to the council um zero carbon
emission pledge thank you
thank you councillor together so
councillor harvey
as the proposal of the initial proposal
and budget et cetera you're able to
speak on this amendment
after you've spoken or decided not to
we'll take a recorded vote on the
dem proposals uh councillor harvey
thank you chairman i'm quite happy to
vote to to move to the vote
i will resist the temptation to point
out some
some obvious rejoinders to the some of
the points that have been made
thank you thank you councillor harvey
for being so brief
right we now move to a recorded vote
on the uh lib dem proposal and i asked
mr buckland to do the roll call
thank you chairman so these are the um
proposals which we circulated earlier
under
agenda item 11. if you could indicate
please when i call your name whether
you're four against or abstaining in
relation to the amendment
that has been put um council uh chairman
council councillor dixon
councillor dixon against thank you
councillor fitter
council officer against thank you
councillor adam
council adam four thank you for all [ __ ]
council all [ __ ] four thank you council
parker
council barker against thank you council
blomidge
councillor bromwich against
council curtis four thank you
against thank you fleming councillor
fleming against
if you cancel the poitic council of joy
tick four
thank you thanks for four months against
thank you councillor ian frenchly answer
ian frankly
for thank you council jenny crutchley
councillor jenny for actually four thank
you councillor harris
councillor harris against thank you
councillor harvey
council harvey against thank you casper
henshaw seraphine
cancer interest in four thank you castle
jefferson
councillor jefferson against thank you
councillor jennings
councillor jennings against thank you of
course
junaid 4 thank you councillor kendall
councillor kendall against thank you
kessler kettle
kettle against thank you mills
council mills against thank you
o'donnell
and councillor o'donnell against thank
you councillor parry
councillor parry against thank you
councillor pemberton
castle pemberton against
thank you guys council roll four
thank you councillor shenton councillor
shenton against
thank you councilman councillor wally
hoggins against
thank you chairman there were 14 votes
four and 21 votes against the um
amendment and therefore the amendment
force
uh mr buckland uh so we now move back to
the
uh original uh proposal unless there are
any other amendments being put if
there is an amendment to be put please
indicate in the chat and do so
fairly promptly
thank you very much indeed right we now
move back to the original proposal by uh
council harvey which uh
we now open to debate uh and uh
i'll open the chat and wait to see if
anybody wishes to speak to
uh to that proposal by council harvey
which was seconded
there's nothing showing in the chat
therefore the uh
proposal has been put has been seconded
we'll now go to a recorded vote
on the initial proposal that is the
conservative
budget uh over to you mr butler
thank you chairman um again we're voting
in relation to the
proposals made by the camera on the 9th
of february
so chairman of the council council
dickson
councillor dixon four thank you uh
councillor peter
councillor for thank you pastor adam
councillor adam against thank you
councillor
[ __ ] counter orc against
thank you councillor barker councillor
bark of four
thank you council bromage
council tonight
we'll come back to council bombage
council target council cargill 4
thank you councillor cleve councillor
cleve against
thank you um councillor curtis
councillor curtis
scott against thank you councilman
that's reading against thank you
cancer fielding four thank you uh
councillor fleming
chancellor fleming four thank you casper
tick
councillor tick four
thank you council jimmy frenchly that's
the journey virtually
against thank you council jackie harris
four thank you councilman harvey
council harvey fall thank you council
hencha seraphin
influencer seraphine against thank you
captain jefferson
councillor jefferson for
councillor jimins councillor jennings
four
thank you that's the junit councillor
jeanette against
thank you council kendall councillor
kendall four
thank you councillor kettle council
catalog for
thank you council mills council rules
for
thank you o'donnell councillor donald
for
thank you kessler riley kevin riley four
thank you rock councillor rock against
the council rolfe councillor off against
thank you council shempton
thank you i will try one further time
for counselor tony grummage are you back
with us
chairman well councillor bromwich hasn't
managed to rejoin the meeting at this
point
he has indicated in the the um chat they
wish to abstain on this matter
taking that into account there were 22
votes for
12 against with one abstention
thank you mr buckland so the uh the
budget has been
approved uh i note that we have now been
going for
just over three hours which means we are
obliged to
decide whether or not this council
meeting is to continue
jimin you muted for the last part of the
statement
uh okay um basically i will propose that
the council continues for another hour
before possibly taking another
vote if anybody wishes to speak against
my proposal
please indicate in the chat but
hopefully somebody will second my
proposal that we continue through
six o'clock
councillor richard i believe you have
vindicated
you chairman yes i'm quite after the
second that we continue
thank you richards in that case we will
indeed
uh continue there's nobody uh indicating
that
a country view at all
so we move through to uh item 17 minute
543 investment in the materials
recycling facility
and i invite councillor shenton as the
operations portfolio holder to introduce
this
item councillor shenton thank you mr
chairman
uh just for clarification at the outset
when i talk about
mirps i'm actually mean material
recycling facility
the backdrop to considering the building
of a murph was very simply that many
murphs are coming to the end of their
life with very few
if any new murphs been built this would
mean that whilst the demand for
facilities would continue to increase
the supply or capacity would decrease
with the result that gate big fees could
in all likelihood accelerate upwards
we could in the worst scenario be in a
position where we had nowhere to place
our recycle at waste
for these reasons we decided along with
our partners
in the project that the best option was
to consider building our own merv
you'll remember that the initial capital
request which was based on a high level
feasibility study
for up to 5.1 million was approved
by council in october 2019
and in recommendation one i'm seeking
approval to replace that
approval with a new request for eight
million pounds
now that the business case has been
firmed up this
also includes a contingency amount of
seven hundred thousand pounds
the market has seen some changes during
the pandemic but even before this many
countries were putting up barriers and
only accepting ultra clean recycle it
plus we are seeing gate fees that is to
say the amount paid to process
the recycling waste increasing
dramatically
it is essential that the product is as
clean as possible with minimal or no
contamination the increased investment
of 8 million will result in a bigger
more flexible turnkey facility that uses
less manual labor and more artificial
intelligence robots and scanners
these can be reprogrammed in minutes
making the facility extremely flexible
this should allow us to end up with
consistently ultra clean recycler
product
which can be sold in the market in
addition as highlighted in in
the papers low grade plastics can be
accommodated more effectively
now low look great plastics include the
problematic cling film product
in short the latest proposal is a far
superior murph
that will stand the test of time and be
more flexible
facility will be the most advanced of
its kind in the uk and one of the most
advanced in the world
provided as i mentioned the turnkey
facility by a company with proven
ability
and solutions in this area of recycling
waste management
deposit return schemes and end user
responsibilities will add additional
challenges
if and when the government does
eventually mandate this but these
challenges
face all murphs we will receive six
percent interest from sherborne
recycling limited
or srl srl for short with the current
public works loan board rates of less
than two percent
we will therefore gain on the interest
the capital will be paid back over a
longer term of 25 years
recommendation too gives a portfolio
holder delegated authority to deal with
matters brought before the shareholder
panel
after consulting with the deputy chief
executive tony perks
and the head of community and
operational services julie lewis
recommendation three is dealing with the
setting up of a loan agreement and
service level agreement
as you know i support this project as it
is the best way to ensure
that we have somewhere to send our
recycler to control the gate fee
which is forecast to continue rising to
control the quality
of the end recycler and to control the
ultimate destination of the processed
product as we have seven other partners
who have separately scrutinized this
project
plus the very experienced respected and
highly qualified george hill
and dare i say councillor chris kettle
who has also cast his eyes over this now
searching questions of the project the
overall view remains that we
should press ahead for all the reasons
i've highlighted
i must also thank tony perks who brought
the initial idea to us and has been a
part of the project since 2019
his expertise and advice has been
invaluable
in summarizing the proposed murph will
be one of the most advanced into in the
world
the gate fee is lower than current and
forecasted future gate fees
we will receive more interest back on
the loan to srl than we pay out
it will last 30 plus years all partners
have subjected the project to scrutiny
and in truth there are no other
realistic options available to us
that don't include a high degree of risk
and higher
gain fees to illustrate this last point
wrap in the latest report
indicate gate fees are currently around
the 53 pound per tonne mark
rising up to 108 pounds per ton
at the lower end therefore of 53 pounds
per ton this would result in the council
costs being some
300 000 pounds above
what the murph will cost in gate fees
at the top end which is more likely
this would mean an extra one million
pounds in costs
that the council taxpayer would need to
underwrite
i therefore ask you to approve the three
recommendations to counsel is contained
on pages 17
and 18 of the supplement to today's
council papers
i'm happy to take questions although the
papers are very detailed and we'll
answer most questions
and there are further details on the
murph industry
in pages two three seven to two five
four of the cabinet papers
thank you councillor you've uh overrun
but you've
pointed out where all the unnecessary
information is
uh so uh councillor wally hoggins has
indicated
that she will second the proposal that
you've just made
and then we've got uh councillor junior
to speak to it as well
and councillor rock uh council wally
hoggins uh to second please
yes i'm more than happy to second this
as as we decline a climate emergency
for many of our residents and many
people sort of
worldwide and in this country actually
some of the things that we're told about
that can help to to save the world uh
very highfaluting but the one
thing that people seem to engage in is
to put waste into blue bins and
appropriate bins
and actually therefore on the most basic
level i commend this
for us and for our residents because
this is more than doing our bits this is
a
glorious achievement that this uh the
proposals that
council shenson puts forwards today
enables
um our residents to recycle more and
more
items with scope for for ever-changing
varieties and for that really i thank
everybody that's brought this to the
table
and i really really support this with my
whole heart because
this this makes a difference and people
residents themselves feel that they are
making a difference
and yes i will admit we do have two blue
bins in this household for a household
of three and we generally fill both bins
in our in our two weekly cycle so i
beseech all of you to commend this and
to approve it thank you
thank you councilor wally hoggins
councillor junaid please
thank you
i was the government liaison officer for
a defra uh
project funded project in circular
economy
uh and headed up the brew center for
local authorities that dealt with local
authority commercial waste projects
so this was my bread and butter i have
seen an awful lot
of uh material recycling facilities in
my time
uh and i do appreciate that the changes
around the world
uh mean that governments around the
world quite rightly no one longer want
to
take our waste that is being exported to
other countries
we have to deal with it ourselves it's
also better
to be able to get good quality um
recycle it
in this country and be able to achieve
proper uh
proper the proper price for it changes
have also made it
very difficult to recruit staff and that
is not going to change in the uh
foreseeable future either
the as i said the circular economy does
demand
much higher quality recycle it and we do
need a very
much a very high technical standard
to be able to achieve that so i actually
support this material recycling facility
and um i i in the current market
they the prices are not going to go down
there is
the the people that are available the
companies that are available in this
market
are few and far between the competition
is is um
is not as great as as you would think
and i think you know the the doing this
between the local authorities
is the way to go so i actually do
approve of this one
thank you counselor counselor rock
please thank you chairman um uh
a lot like the portfolio holder and
susan june and i support this scheme it
was
i think it's exactly the way we should
be going and i
just got a couple of observations to
make first of all i think the thing
that's very welcome is the inclusion of
a photovoltaic
electrodes degeneration scheme um within
within the proposal so i think that's
very welcome
and uh well justified for the money um
i think we do need to keep an eye on
cost control these major projects
uh particularly when involved local
government can tend to spiral away and i
would commend that uh
level of control for the team i'm sure
they have an eye on that but
um i'm sure the opposition will be
keeping an eye on those figures
however the one question and and uh
councillor shenton said you would ask to
answer the questions we asked
the one question that's concerning me is
um i wonder if he can help
help us out with the corporate status of
sherbourne recycling limited
sherbourne recycling limited don't
appear to be registered at company's
house
and i can't find them on uh credit
checkers
and they're specifically mentioned
several times as a corporate entity
so who are who is this as a corporate
entity
uh are they registered could anybody
else not hire jack the name
and so the money went to the wrong place
and who are the
who are the directors of uh sherbourne
recycling limited it been apparently a
limited company thank you chairman
thank you council iraq councillor riley
next uh
questions to the portfolio holder will
come at the end of the debate
castle riley thank you chair
i want to add my support to this
scheme the benefits i see
are the removal of the risk
of the unavailability of commercial
recycling
facilities in the district
and the fact that this will be processed
relatively locally to here
rather than trades all across the
country um
and the fact that because we're in
partnership with our authorities
um we as fcc have some control over it
so for those reasons i support these
this
proposal thank you thank you council
riley
uh nobody else has indicated a wish to
speak so councillor shenton you can
answer that question
put by councillor rock alternatively you
might perhaps take it out of the uh
after the meeting but uh over to you
councillor shenton
yeah just very quickly the um i'd have
to check on the corporate status of
sherbourne recycling limited or
srl as it's commonly known i haven't
checked on
uh to be quite honest on the company
test but
the shareholders will be uh from
each of the authorities uh effectively
this
is owned by this sherborne recycling
limited will be owned by the partner
councils
uh it's done at arms lengths effectively
um
so there are no no problems with
procurement in in the future
and the monies won't be going anywhere
until
um if if until and
it is properly uh properly formulated
now as far as i'm aware because
that name is the one that's been given
all the way along it is registered it
may be registered as srl limited i
haven't
haven't checked that but it certainly
the shareholders will be the councils
there are two two levels of board and i
won't bore you with all the details at
the moment
but if you want to cancel rock i will
gladly
uh walk you through them um after
after the meeting or uh at another time
thank you councillor shenton uh so the
uh proposal has been put it has been
seconded by council ollie huggins
uh there's nobody else indicating in the
chat so
i think given the uh the nature of the
debate the support that it has found
um i'll just give it a moment for
anybody to indicate in the chat that
they wish to
uh object to the proposal uh other than
that we'll take it as a as
agreed i'll just give it a moment
nobody indicating in that case that
proposal is agreed
as item 17 we now move through
to agenda item 12.
minute 541 treasury management
statement strategy statement pardon and
the annual investment strategy for
2021 22 to consider the recommendations
from the cabinet as contained in that
minute
and i invite councillor harvey as the
finance asset portfolio holder to
introduce this
item counselor harvey thank you chairman
i will be as succinct as i can
there's an annual requirement under the
guidance issued by the ministry for
housing communities and local government
for councils to draw up and approve an
annual
investment strategy that meets the
chartered institute of public finance
and accountancy's
treasury management code of practice
this council's proposed treasury
management strategy for the forth coming
year
is set out in the supplementary report
which has been revised to take account
of the additional three million pounds
capital expenditure on the material
recycling facility project at the
cabinet meeting on the 9th of february i
drew attention
of members of the cabinet to just one
aspect of the strategy and that was
on page 183 members saw that the
expectation for investment returns in
the immediate future remained
exceptionally low and given the
uncertain times in which we lived the
prospect of any rise
in investment returns was both uncertain
and modest
the proposed capital and investment
strategy for the period
2021-22 to 2025-26
was set out on pages 205-216
of the papers considered on the 9th of
february
that proposal provided the framework
within which it's intended the council
should make its capital and investment
decisions
over the next five years on the
assumption that councillors have been
able to familiarize themselves with
these papers
and subject to any questions they may
have i ask
that approval is given to
recommendations one to four
as set out in the paper now before the
council
thank you chairman thank you councillor
harvey
uh right that's a proposal having been
put i now
call for a second uh for councillor
harvey's proposals
councillor cargill you've indicated in
the chapter second can you please put
that verbally to the meeting
i'm happy to second this proposal
i'll now give a while in the chat for
anybody to indicate they wish to speak
on this item
if not we will take it as agreed
okay thank you very much indeed so
that's a minute outside gender item
12 has been agreed obviously we've got
a lot to try and get through as quickly
as we can
now moving through to agenda items 13
minute 542 prudential indicators
to consider the recommendations again
from the cabinet as contained in minute
542
of this meeting held on the 9th of
february and i invite
councillor harvey uh to introduce this
item council harvey thank you chairman
in conjunction with considering its
budget for the forthcoming year the
council is required
by the chartered institute of public
finance and the constancy's
prudential code to set prudential
indicators
that ensure that its capital investment
plans are affordable
prudent and sustainable paper in support
for gender item 13 sets out the factors
that the council
through its section 151 officer is
required to take into account
when considering the affordability in
its particular circumstances
of its intended capital expenditure over
the period of the medium-term financial
strategy
and the affordability of the capital
finance requirement to which this
intended expenditure may give rise
councillors have noted the intention to
incur an expenditure of 5 million pounds
in relation to the materials recycling
facility and the financing requirement
to which this will give rise
the section 151 officer has satisfied
himself
that the terms associated with this
course of action will
in his view meet the relevant
requirements
the section 151 officer has also noted
the recommendation to council
that has now been considered and
approved earlier in the meeting
that the amount of the loan in
connection with the material recycling
facility
of 5 million pounds should be increased
to 8 million pounds
for the purpose of this paper the
section 151 officer
is able to state that taking this into
account
he would continue to be satisfied that
the requirements of paragraph
2.7 of the paper considered by the
cabinet on the 9th of
february 2021 would be met
councillors are therefore asked to
approve the recommendations set out in
minute
542 as circulated that the proposed
prudential indicators for the
forthcoming year
be approved thank you chairman
thank you catherine harvey uh i require
a second in respect of that proposal put
by capital harvey
councillor barca please
happily second
thank you guys for the barker that was a
uh a very
weak second thing i must admit my uh the
volume on mine is definitely
i'll give you a stronger second happy
second that's much better thank you very
much indeed councillor parker
um okay if nobody indicates in the chat
any um comments etc we will take that
gain as a
as an agreed item i'll just give that a
short
pause
fine nothing indicating in the chat so
that's
uh agenda item 13 concluded and the item
agreed
moving on to agenda item 14 the council
tax uh
chairman to inform the meeting that in
accordance with the local authorities
standing orders england amendments
regulations 2014
a recorded vote will be taken on the
council tax 2122
and i now invite councillor pemberton uh
as the deputy leader of the council to
introduce this item
councillor tony jefferson having uh not
been
too well he's uh withdrawn from the
meeting already
councillor pemberton thank you chairman
again i'll try and keep this brief um
members we
have agreed on our budget and the
natural consequence of that
is to then set the council tax
for the coming municipal year so the
recommendation on page 43
in front of members is to approve the
formal council tax resolution
at appendix 1 which can be found on page
45
of your papers um
i will be looking for a secondary in
fact i see councillor barker has
indicated
to second i'm sure she will be
loud enough to do that for the chair to
hear but other than that
i think i will leave it at that thank
you chairman thank you councillor
pemberton councillor barker
very happy to second
thank you councillor barker uh i'll now
give it a pause
in the in the chat if no comments come
through
we will have the recorded vote uh
that is required in respect to setting
the council tax
chairman thank you very much again if i
call your name could please indicate
that you're fought against
or saving for the um the council tax
resolution um chairman of council
councillor dixon
councillor dixon four thank you
councillor fitter
councillor fitzer four thank you adam
councillor adam four thank you counselor
all cop
counselor all cargo full thank you
council barca
councillor thank you vomit
council of romage abstain
[Music]
harris
council jackie harris
welcome back to chrisley house council
harvey council harvey four
thank you pastor henry sarah quinn
cancellation serving for
the council jefferson i believe has left
the meeting
mr jefferson okay
councillor jennings council jennings
paul
thank you junit
councillor june 84 thank you councillor
kendall
councillor kendall four thank you
council kettle
councillor kettle for thank you
councillor mills
council mills for thank you coachella
o'donnell
richards council richards thank you
kessler riley
kenton riley four if you get a rock
councillor rock four thank you
councillor rolfe
council ralph fought thank you captain
shenton
that's the shenzhen four thank you
council
wally hoggins
councillor hoggins four thank you i will
go back to council jackie harris are you
there
chairman i had 52 votes for with one
extension thank you
thank you mr bartland so item 14 has
been
taken um item
16 and item 22 are items which we must
clear this afternoon we still have 25
minutes before
the opportunity for another vote
i doubt if we will possibly under any
circumstances get the cyrus
capsules questions and therefore my
proposal
at six o'clock will be certainly that
that item is
taken by way of supplementaries by email
to the leader and answers provided by
way of
response which then be published to all
and published on the website
but we'll now move on please to item 16
and this is minute five three nine
the joint cabinet executive committee of
the strata navy and the white district
councils
to consider that again the
recommendation from the cabinet uh from
the 9th of february and i invite
councillor pemberton
as deputy leader to introduce this item
councillor pemberton
thank you chair and in relation to your
proposals these are the uh
lead leaders questions i'm sure that the
leader will be glad
uh that i am not afforded the
opportunity to answer on his behalf
that world of trouble i can avoid thank
you very much chair
members this item is in relation to the
additional governance arrangements
around the south warwickshire local plan
members will all will be aware that
there has already been
established a joint member working group
starting the sort of ground work on this
which has held two meetings which have
been
very successful in starting starting the
work forward and
uh have been are getting quite a move on
with that so
the next sort of level of governance is
the proposition for
a joint uh committee drawn from members
of the district councils
cabinet and warwick district council's
executive
so so members the recommendation to
council
is that subject to warwick district
council passing
resolutions to the same effect which we
fully expect to
happen at their next meeting next week
that it is agreed to prepare joint local
development documents with warwick
district council
pursuant to section 28 of the planning
compulsory purchase act 2004
that the proposed constitution of the
joint committee which is set out in
appendix
1 of the cabinet report and members
have cabinet papers in front of them be
adopted
the third recommendation is that the
constitution of stratfor district
council
is amended so that only items that are
key decisions taken by the joint
committee
uh can be called in uh a bit of
background there is that uh
in addition to our own overview and
scrutiny committee warwick district
council have in fact
two overview and scrutiny committees and
that the chairs of
each of the three uh scrutiny committees
across stratford and warwick district
councils
meet early in 2021 may 2021
to consider the potential for joint
scrutiny arrangements
uh to scrutinize the work of this joint
committee um
that would be a really big step forward
in uh
in helping us move together to have some
joint scrutiny but that is for further
down the track so
those are the recommendations for
council i'm looking for a second or if i
may
chair um happy
looking for a second yeah
uh counselor junaid to uh to speak i'm
um
it's frozen again but counselor
counselor junit please
yes i just want to make the point uh
that i'm not averse to this but i do
want to make the point again
as we did before that
as wide as wide a possible consultation
with councillors
on very important issues to do with the
local plan
are essential and that this is properly
scrutinized
uh and um i i would hope that you would
not
you would um uh apply the the
um what you said earlier about widening
consultation
to this also to make sure that we're all
kept fully informed
and all kept fully involved as much as
possible i think really do you think
this is important
thank you chair apologies uh tech let me
down either that or the leader cut me
off so i apologize i missed councillor
junizin's
comments there
it was just to make sure that you did
you took the point that we made earlier
although this is the local plan
um but you still took the point that we
made earlier that we do need
wide consultation and keeping everybody
informed
and that there should be proper and due
scrutiny um because the local plan is an
important um thing for our residents so
thank you very much indeed just just
happy to happy to give that assurance uh
the thing couldn't fly without
it
i believe that castle barker will be the
seconder for this uh proposal
of recommendations castle barca i'm
happy to second the recommendation
thank you councillor parker uh sorry
about the confusion here my chat
just seems to be here there and
everywhere at the moment um
so i'll just give it a moment for
anybody else to indicate in the chat
should it actually appear in mine
and
then we'll move through to a
and then do we have to vote on this one
no no if
uh if there's nothing here we'll that
recommendation is agreed and approved uh
thank you very much indeed we'll
straight we'll move straight through now
to the other item which desperately has
to be done today
and that is item 22
which is the audit and standards
committee
proposals report and at this point i
would like to
invite the council of foreign to as the
vice chair
of that committee to introduce this item
so i believe that she will be
inviting mr buckland to also speak
councillor foreman
thank you chair um members since the
agenda was issued there has been some
subsequent changes
um these have become necessary as we
need to make sure our polling stations
are
safe and secure to all electors and
staff
so can i please hand over to david
buckland to explain these changes to
you thank you thank you thank you
chairman
i i would be very grateful i will thank
members for all their interventions so
far
with the proposals that we originally
issued which were subsequently then
amended before they went to audit and
service committee and thank you
particularly the councillors for coming
up with venues and other parish councils
who are also
suggesting developed venues but we must
be clear here
the overriding priority s council
performance has just suggested
he said the elections which will be
undertaken on the 6th of may
are conducted in the most coveted secure
way possible
and quite simply some of our venues that
we have used in the past just wouldn't
be possible to achieve that standard
to protect both the electorate and our
staff
the further changes which have been
necessitated
relate to wixford where
we are now suggesting instead of temple
grafton that is arrow british hall which
is used
in relation to aiden dassett
unfortunately the reading room at agenda
is not
suitable but the utree public house
within avonda has been identified as an
alternate venue
and therefore we will be spending the
afternoon in the pub just just
looking at the um the prime minister's
announcement
it's unlikely that in side hospitality
will be open at that point in any case
and therefore that should be um
a suitable venue other changes which
have been forced upon us
temple hardwood school has been
indicated is not available and therefore
the electorate that would normally go
there
will be diverted to gade and village
hall in shuttering
the shuttering memorial hall will be
used
given that the race courses indicate
that we cannot use their venue on this
occasion either
in studly uh studly village hall has
been
earmarked as a vaccination center
unfortunately
that thought means it won't be a very
versatile on our elections
and therefore we will have to be holding
the elections in studly
leisure center the chairman i i would
ask your support on this item for
what is not a political matter but it is
a health and safety matter
this afternoon thank you thank you david
um therefore there are two
recommendations on page
58 of the agenda and i propose both
these recommendations to members
thank you thank you councillor and i
need a second
for that uh proposal of your own
uh have a a second in respect of the
audit and standards uh proposal from uh
capital foreman
cap councillor harvey i think you've
indicated
i have i'm happy to second thank you
councillor harvey
lovely marco might have pointed i'm i'm
i'm being advised that counselor junior
is indicated
i'm not sure that that is the case um
that seems to be something in my chat
that's about 10 minutes old
uh counselor junior were you wanting to
speak on this item no i was not
thank you thank you very much counselor
junaid uh
councillor barker you've indicated
points of information i'm not sure
there is such a thing as a well a point
of order then because you because there
are several items being missed here
that have to go through because they
have dates attached to them
um items item 18 and item 19.
i simply moved something forward i
didn't delete those items we're going
back to them if there is time
no what i'm saying is we have to make
time
they have a date we we hope to make
time and the sooner we have a special
counsel meeting to put these through
these two things through
that's a lot of date in early march
yes we will indeed be getting those
through if we can actually move on
through this item
we've now had a proposal and a second in
respect of the agenda item 22.
has anybody anything against item 22
on the agenda
i don't see i don't see anything in the
chat so uh
the proposals and recommendations of
minute five four
five one four are gleed we can now move
back
to item 18 on the agenda
which is the minute 544 preventing
homelessness in warwickshire
a multi-agency approach we have 15
minutes to go before six o'clock
uh and i call on councillor barker
to introduce this item councilor barker
thank you
um forgive me i'm not going to do
anything more than a fast trot through
this
you'll see the recommendations on page
255
of the cabinet agenda of the 9th of
february
the key issues here are that this is a
this is part of forming a workshop
housing board seeking approval
from the health and well-being board to
do a hope to form a homelessness
strategic group
this is a multi-agency group and the
strategy takes into account health to
reduce inequalities improve the health
of people at risk of homelessness
financial inclusion appropriate services
particularly homeless people
young people ditto domestic abuse ditto
and offending ditto
and as councillor kettle has raised with
me particularly important
are our former service men and women as
well
um as you'll see on page 257 veterans
are important so without saying anymore
i would
recommend items uh sorry
the summary of one two and three to the
council that the strategic vision
is recommended for preventing
homelessness in warwickshire and across
warwickshire thank you
thank you parker i believe councillor
junior wishes to speak to this item
councillor junaid all i want to say is
that our group
uh supports both items 18 and 19
and are proposed to second uh supposed
to support this
thank you councillor do you know if
that's kind of let's take a councillor
junior councillor parry i believe you
are
to second this item
very pleased to second uh the
recommendation
chair thank you councillor parry
so we have uh councillor wally hogan
wishing to speak to it councilor wally
hoggins
yes it's just a point really i do feel
as if we are
um um speeding up here and that people
are being quiet because of the timing
issues here with
with everything that's been that's been
discussed and i'm concerned that we're
not giving
very important matters uh the due
process and discussions and debates
that they need simply because people are
aware that it's ten to six in the
evening and people want the tea and the
catneys letting out so i'm just saying
that
you know i'm concerned that we're
rushing things here you know these are
all really important matters
and for the residents that they affect
uh you know we shouldn't be rushing like
this if we need to postpone
then we need to do so but this you know
there is a sense of gravitas here
for for full council meetings anyway
rant's over thank you okay could i just
come in at that point that these two
items were very very uh dealt with in
great depth
at the overview and scrutiny committee
and i proposed and supported them
at that ovun scrutiny committee as did
the members of my group that were there
at the time thank you councillor junaid
for that
so the proposal has been put by
councillor barker
i don't think we called for a second at
the time but uh
uh councillor kettle uh would you like
to speak to it and possibly second that
uh
proposal by council of barca uh very
happy second proposal to councillor
barca i thought it had been seconded but
i would also like to
thank the reassurance on behalf of
veterans
uh that those less fortunate veterans
will be covered by this
this item uh but i'm very happy to
second it
thank you shall i move on to the next
one
so i'm assuming that we have accepted
the preventive template strategy
great i will now i'll now move on to
item
19 health and well-being strategy again
this is something that's been well
rehearsed
um and the reason that i'm the only
reason i'm rushing it excuse me
councillor barker we're still on item 18
and the chair decides whether this item
is finished or not thank you
sorry councilor barker i was trying to
survive through the
various comments in the chat i've now
managed to
pick them up the counselor cleve and
councillor henshaw seraphin have left
the meeting
so the proposal introspective 18 a
gender item 18 has been put and has been
seconded
and if there are no further comments in
the chat on that particular
item we will approve that issue
right there's no indications in the chat
so that one is now agreed
we can now move through to item 19 which
we do know
has been well uh discussed
at the osc but nevertheless it does have
to be put
and i invite councillor barca portfolio
to introduce
item 19 minute 545.
i'd like to say that i'm extremely
grateful
to councillor wally hoggins um for the
point she makes about how important
these two strategies are they really are
we don't have time to go into them
deeply tonight for which i'm really
sorry
there are really really good reports
written and i would commend them to you
um in terms of the health and wellbeing
strategy again the reason this has to go
through
is because the meeting of the health and
wellbeing board on the third of march is
where this goes to as well
and we have to go with the
recommendations
this runs from 20 20 20 to 20 25
and the recommendations are on page 335
of the 9th of february cabinet papers
i won't run through them but i would
make the point that item 4 is a proposal
that we consider adding a further
category for mandatory inclusion in all
reports
on the health detailing what the
implications of the report on the health
and well-being of district residents
and that we should be improving that and
that's the one i that that's
that's the one sort of outstanding thing
that i think you should take notice of
apart from reading it
thoroughly and knowing that mental
health
has been the fit the issue that has been
put right up there as a priority i
commend this to this strategy to you and
i'll keep working on it on the health
and well-being board
thank you thank you very much councillor
barker councillor parry has indicated
that you will second this item
councillor parry please
thank you chair i'm delighted to second
this recommendation and could i just
add my thanks to councillor barker and
all the team
for this excellent piece of work it is
totally crucial and um even more
important to see
the welfare and mental health well-being
right up as a priority so thank you very
much councillor barker
thank you councilor parry right uh i
should just give it a moment for anybody
else to indicate in the chat that they
wish to speak to agenda item 19
if not that will be taken as an agreed
item
i'll just give that a pause
okay nobody's indicated there so that's
uh
minute five four five health and
wellbeing strategy has been
agreed
i'll now move on to item
20 minute 491 the pay policy statement
2122 the annual review and i invite
councillor pemberton
as deputy leader to introduce this item
thank you thank you
thank you chair the employment and
appointments committee as it must do
each year has
considered the pay policy and the review
and members uh the recommendation to
cancel is that the
pay policy is the pay policy statement
has appended to the agenda report be
adopted for the period
21 22 and i seek
a a seconder for that and we'll take any
questions if there are any thank you
chair thank you very much councillor
pemberton
uh councillor harvey i think you've
indicated to us a second
uh i have indeed i'm very happy to
second
very much thank you
tell me you're muted
apologies to councillor jennings you
were uh
you did just beat councillor harvey but
i didn't spot that one
um so it's been proposed and seconded uh
i'll just give it a moment for anybody
to comment in the chat if not
that too will be an agreed item
thank you members that's an agreed item
so
we can move on to uh item
21 minute 507 the statement of the
licensing policy
and i invite councillor mills as
chairman of regulatory committee to
introduce this
item council bill thank you very much mr
chairman
at the meeting of the regulatory
committee on the 29th
of uh january 2021
consideration was given to the statement
of licensing policy
in line with regulations the policy must
be reviewed every five years
following a review by the licensing team
and neighboring authorities no
significant changes were made
the draft policy policy has been through
an extensive
six-week consultation with all the
responsible
responsible authorities as well as the
public no
adverse comments were made during this
period mr chairman i therefore propose
to the council that as per the
recommendation
found on page 56 of the agenda the
statement of licensing policy for the
period
2021 to 2026
be received and adopted mr chairman
thank you
thank you councillor mills can i see a
seconder for that one
uh councillor harvey you've said it
i have indeed mr chairman i'm happy to
second
thank you very much councillor harvey
i'll just give that a moment in the chat
for anybody to indicate that they wish
to speak to it
other than that it too will be an agreed
and approved item
fine thank you very much members that
one has been agreed
we've now moved through thank you
minute 20 agenda item 23
the employment appointments committee
minute 555 the appointment of the
section 151
officer and i invite councillor
pemberton as deputy leader of the
council to introduce this item
councilor pembington thank you chair uh
at its meeting of the employment
and appointments committee on the 16th
of february um
the committee resolved to recommend to
cancel the appointments
of a joint section 151 statutory officer
with warwick
district council and members
are asked to approve said recommendation
thank you councillor pemberton i see
councillor june head
unit has requested to speak to this item
counselor junior
it is mainly just place on record my
thanks
to uh george hill for all the help that
he has given
uh while he has been with the council
particularly to our group so thank you
thank you councillor junaid uh right
we've had it uh proposed by councillor
uh pemberton uh looking for a
second uh
i think councilwoman harvey possibly uh
councillor harvey have you
have you agreed to second uh that uh
proposal by accounts of the pemberton
i have indeed chairman i'm happy to
second
thank you very much indeed uh so let's
i'll just give it uh
a moment in the chat
nothing appearing so item agenda item 23
minute 555 the appointment the section
one five off
has been agreed and approved so
it is now just coming up to six o'clock
and it is my proposal
that the questions and the remaining
items
are dealt with by way of email to the
councillors and officers and answers
supplementary etc can then be published
via emails and also published onto the
website
do i have uh anybody disagreeing with
that such a proposal or would they like
to
carry on with this meeting i trust not
okay i'm the the feedback i'm getting is
not through the chat
it is a situation whereby the one item
that we
perhaps can hear is councillor
pettigelda is still with us hopefully
yes she is um is the uh obviously motion
item agenda item 27 notice of motions
um tackling food insecurity and
promoting food injustice
uh councillor pertiguela obviously your
motion has been printed it has been
published
uh if you would like to just move the
motion and then we'll have that second
it obviously
will be referred uh under the council
procedural rules
uh et cetera councillor peter geller
would you like to
propose the motion you don't need to
speak to it at this time
yes i know thank you chair so i would
like to formally propose the motion
of tackling food insecurity and
promoting
food justice locally thank you
thank you councillor personella and the
most emotion being seconded by
it's been seconded by um neil either
eden
councillor eddon uh would you like to
just uh formally uh second that proposal
notice of motion rather i'd be more than
happy to second that notices of motion
chair thank you
thank you councillor eddon so
that notice of motion will go uh for
uh counts under the council procedural
rules etc
to be re report back once proposing
secondly be referred to the cabinet for
consideration
and report without debate um
there is one other item which
um i'm being flagged up uh if we can as
it is
simply for noting um i'm sorry about the
the way we're jumping about the agenda
uh today
but uh agenda item 24 the annual update
from outside bodies
is to receive a written report from
members representing the outside bodies
and i invite councillor pemberton
as deputy leader of the council to
introduce this item which is a
report for noting of the council of
pemberton
thank you chair uh members of council
are asked to
note the report at appendix one from the
members of outside bodies
thank you chair
the item the item for the outside bodies
has been noted
item 28 now i'm told is just a noting
and it receives it refers to noting the
urgent business item off-street car
parking charges that went
to the 9th of february 221 cabinet
meeting
will be displayed on the screen
so that item has been noted
thank you
without any further ado uh i'm not being
asked to do anything else from my fellow
there's no further business this uh
council meeting after
four hours is now finished thank you
very much
members for your time and your efforts
and your
well-meaning attitudes etc etc thank you
very much indeed a long meeting
thank you very much